dude let's let's roll cuz I got some
[ __ ] I want to say let's go let's lift I
want to say some [ __ ] I'm feeling good
feeling pumped we'll get into it ok I'm
ready to get into it I'm ready to
best-lookin red head on planet earth
he's it yeah by the way by the way I
took good there's not many of you are
there
no there's about six six or seven no in
the kid works old unit think there's six
good-looking redheads in five are women
that's right yep yeah you're right
rolling I'd say you and Canelo yeah well
he's not but he's um he's like minimun
well that's what it is yeah but Mexican
he saw it he's already got sexy dark
skin so he's not only one of a height
bro he's like you might know he's not as
these not as long as he is lies there's
no there's no chance he's that way you
guys have the same body but I don't
think it's when he can get he can
actually get tense so a lot of red has a
lot of gingers smoldering the Sun yeah
they get burned you've got Santino's i
say you know is it young Siciliano now
my my godfather Horne
take a seat for sex I guess my notes are
your family here see my my my Maya my
godfather
yeah Redman Gemelli Redman melimeli
Sicilian is that a dress already just as
red as you are but with that brown kind
of thing that Archie from the comic
books yeah yeah Archie is cool he's a
good-looking kid
thank you you look good you look really
good well some wait for the last time I
saw you Santino the great comic and I'm
glad I don't want to get into that but
but thank you for saying it because
yesterday this is important I I did a
CrossFit workout now I went I went
pull-ups
I went dips dip and then I went went
bench now my upper body was screaming
yeah I can imagine yeah oh my god no no
like and then I went I'll give you a
break my buddy was a thank you and then
I go but we're getting under the squat
rack and then we're gonna pause the
ladies bottom oh yeah how long you
taking two second pause so it's a five
it's five down and then bursts back up
then I worked for 14 hours then I walked
my kids to school I got a lot of [ __ ]
going on and he's wearing those shoes it
doesn't add up be well you were on you
worked out till you get school but then
you work 48 hour
so I worked out I had a one o'clock call
I worked out call time yes sir okay in
the afternoon I worked until quickmask
18 hours I work actually worked 13 hours
I rapped at 2 o'clock exactly in the
morning you am yes that was a lot of fun
woke up walk my kids to school
I still got energy you're wearing those
shoes you follow the UFC I can do this
you have the worst shoes I've ever seen
you will do oh man you have really bad
you do CrossFit in them guys show show
the people at home how awesome I sorry
it says they're running with three
months and business long there are those
thin business come on hey let's see my
bottom of those paper mache do you not
have real socks bright yeah I do but I
wore these because they've they don't
crowd my toes
you're embarrassing you're embarrassing
as a man your friend I gotta get out of
here you guys are [ __ ] I'm dude
Thank You Man
you listen you worked a 14-hour day you
were bragging yeah I get it you're
making lots of money or mr. Goldberg
yeah I mean well you're mister I'm dying
up here
that's god yes we died yes yeah they
killed the show you've not seasons
though right two seasons yeah but the
second one was like really like that was
like really that's what I said when they
called me and I was up in Mammoth ma'am
I got a call in the mountains and I had
got to my phone those like 15 missed
calls and it was my agent was like hey
they picked up that show and I was like
seriously Wow why Siri because we had
seven people watch it the first season
any of your listeners like oh I've never
heard of that show in my entire life we
do two seasons on Showtime
yeah Showtime massive Network seven
people saw it yeah my mom my dad my aunt
Carol
barb my neighbor me my old landlord and
you yeah well what did you think of the
show I didn't see it as a comic thanks
for watching the product I know it was
it was based loosely around the comi
storm yes so like the quickest way I can
do this because I don't want to spend
too much time on it cuz it so please
talk about your over talk about my dad
that left - yeah
just that time you Bob yeah come on look
at me
ya know it was there's a book called him
dying up here this guy William no
settler that wrote it years ago it's
basically about the history of the
Comedy Store and then in the 70s around
the strike for people that don't know
that was a big deal
and he was good friends with Richard
Lewis that's kind of the impetus for
this whole thing yeah yeah beaucoup you
remember the beaucoup commercials do you
remember those yeah he he was kind of
impetus for the whole show for the whole
book in terms of the lens of which the
writer got to see the comedy store right
anyway long story does the book who had
it up great that is beaucoup that
commercial was so terrible for me that
was a fruit drink in a box that's what
it was they were today's root drink in a
box so anyway yes we're loosely based on
the Comedy Store in the 70s but we
talked about the store because we didn't
have the legal right to say we were the
Comedy Store you didn't have the legal
right we were called the gold or didn't
dude you want to crack that case cuz the
practice because the mitzi was not was
not into that when she was alive ever
and then when she passed which is when
Jim approached the shore family about it
Jim Carrey yeah they were because Jim
Carrey produced it they were like no we
can't you guys can't use the name made
that club like he's one of the guys that
made that club in its heyday correct him
and Robin and Pryor I mean there were
guys that like were the biggest names of
yeah comedy at that place you could also
argue that admits he made that club in
the sense you know what I mean no
comments from a part of it he was the he
was the coolest young I mean look he was
the to this day he was the highest-paid
comedic actor of all time you know with
no training you know who came out of
nowhere no name another guy they got
twenty million dollars a film after like
three years of being in film didn't
exist yeah I mean Kevin Hart might be
the closest guy to it in our generation
but even Kevin you know I don't know I
don't think even he's getting that kind
of scale so also carries ability to do
his range as an actor it's weird that
here's how he was Tommy store wouldn't
do it she was always yeah but I know
it's like I forget who it was maybe the
Tomica Marin Show was saying how
he was like he thought the problem with
the shows they didn't show enough of how
fun Oh Leto had Leno Leno was saying
yeah my shoe with the show as I watch it
it was a great time at the time he said
there was too much angst we're just
literally my issue with the show was I
was like man this is too too much way
too dark that's the best hanging out
effort yeah show they should have made
it way more fun but again that was also
like all that stuff you do enough TV you
know it's out of your hand at some point
you're like I'm just not really kidding
falls on your shoulders you know the
Comedy Store though like 10 years ago
and more yeah well actually when I first
got to LA was 1968 68 yeah The Comedy
Store was such Charlie Chaplin chaotic
place like right now it's a really
profitable everybody from all over the
world comes back in the day like I'm
talking about five years ago it was not
only dead but it was just there were
secret rooms [ __ ] went on that place
yeah I moved to LA in 2006 and when I
first started trying to go to Mike's
there all I remember is how awful of a
place it was it was disgusting you came
out of Boston Chicago I'm from Chicago
but I moved from college I came from
here from car I came to the Arizona
State that's a fine institution what did
you study
yeah yeah what did you study I was there
I did I think I snuck around I snuck
around for four years they let me stay
yeah my father was like are you having
trouble going to class I was like you
know I'm here
butI vomited yeah at the time it was the
cheapest out-of-state school in the
country I probably was paying $2,000 a
year to go to Arizona
what a great they just needed people
they were like come on over we don't
even care what you're doing here we just
want to film numbers because they wanted
to be Texas they want to be the biggest
school in the country when did you do
the biggest parties you know it's funny
because I didn't know I live my
deduction you was you were up on state
you were about to go onstage at the
Laugh Factory and three or four younger
comics cuz you gotta watch this guys
have you seen Andrew Santino and I went
I swear to God and they went no and then
I was ready I don't know probably
literally three years weeks yeah too
much oh he just found out about writers
but it was yeah I was like we're
this [ __ ] guy come from out of
nowhere left-field yeah yeah I said I
stayed away from the store for a long
long time why that whole scene was not
the people that go today they have no
idea what it was like this also a lot of
the older generation when I first came
in was not so pleasant now they were not
from now like as a as a regular there of
the the people that are working at that
Club the young guys that come in I'm
always nice to those guys it wasn't like
that used to be like get the [ __ ] out of
here it was it was just you weren't
welcome
what do you 20 years ago when I first
got up on stage and showcase for mitzi I
bombed no yeah it was 20 actually was 20
years ago I did my stuff and no one
laughed and I had three minutes yeah and
they were light and Rogan Joe Rogan
recommended me oh he did that's what US
really that's always nice to get regular
is it and I was so turned off by that
place yeah it was such an awful
experience that I didn't go back until
well 10 years 11 years later oh wow
and even then it wasn't even as good as
it didn't start to get my views when did
you started doing all this acting uh
thousand and ten the first thing I ever
did was I got this like little hosting
job and after I did the hosting job they
asked me to do like this online series
for MSN and after that I I just started
to try my hand and stuff and then I did
in 2010 I they pumped when they did
Punk'd again I fin it like the very last
season that Punk'd had done I joined up
with those guys you do for a punk I was
on it that's a great I wrote the show
and I was on it oh wow I did a lot for
those guys for Ashton and Goldberg that
they they were like you know they were
making other pilots in the meantime he's
like I think we're gonna do Punk'd again
and I had written like to other
hidden-camera shows me and Ian Edwards
wrote this Comedy Central pilot for them
I had just met Ian he with open arms was
like you know helped me out learn how to
write sketches for Comedy Central we
wrote this pilot that I thought I talked
about a ton Rogan I thought was one of
the funny things I've ever done and it
never went anywhere but we wrote some
amazing catches like incredibly funny
well I told I did this I talked about
this on Rogan recently but like we did a
sketch called melon and Mayo where the
star the show was his black Adele share
we convince people in test group that
mayonnaise they were eating that was
dyed brown was going to give them
melanin
skin but we told them after they ate the
sandwiches so those white people are
like I'm gonna go black I'm gonna go
black lost her brain we wrote a bunch of
amazing sketches yeah they lost them I
do we did they almost tried a bunch of
awards threatening to sue anyway oh my
god we wrote a bunch of that just but
anyway that was my intro to that world
and then I did Punk'd and after Punk'd I
slowly started getting in you know I did
the office I did a few different start
in the office yeah you had the second
last season yeah I did I did in college
I did journalism and I did a little bit
of theatre I was the Oh Mike this in my
creative writing class this woman came
in and was looking for people to like
fill in for this play and she had said
she was like oh I can tell that you have
you have you have something more than
your like putting on because you're
you're big and you're you know you're
loud you're just pretending that you
don't know how to do it you should come
try so the first thing I ever did for
this woman was I did a vagina the vagina
monologues I was the only guy yeah doing
playing a guy who beats his who beats
his pregnant wife oh yeah I mean it's so
true to life so it was easy for me I've
been hidden pregnant women for years
right hand oh man it's already these
nuts
oh look at some of these photos some of
those are real terrible eyes Joe Mande
on there what would an ad who's the guy
that's doing all that off ha what's that
who's again the cutoff shirt that's me
bro it's leather daddy
Santino puts on muscle easily yes and
why why did you do that why did I do
that why wouldn't I do that great the
photographer said I got this weird
leather jacket I said of course and it's
not laughing at that that's a great
clothes and then Oscar Nunez is above me
hold on hold on B who's the guy with the
shirt off is that Santino oh you are
buddy
that's looking good he's Robbie you God
dude you are a good-looking ginger look
at you look at the top of those pubes
thank you
look at it you could see the base of his
dick right there that's not a jump in a
group room that's the root a stump and
oh the roots baby roots anyway get all
these pictures off of me
go anywhere else anywhere else come back
to Chicago a lot I [ __ ] love it oh
yeah man my I was just saying the other
day how much I miss it I get I get in I
get in these mood to twice a year in the
dog days of summer which is right now
and right before Christmas I'm like I
can't live here anymore I gotta go back
to Chicago in the winters I don't care
don't even care dahhh I don't even care
you know why cuz you get around each
other and you eat food and you drink and
you hang out this whole like XYZ is bad
in the winter
no one cares they're they [ __ ] about it
but we really are like it gives us an
opportunity to sit in a room to get shut
down in LA City don't know you don't sit
in a room with anybody unless you're
doing a podcast or a meeting yeah yeah
when's the last time you just like hey
come over we'll all sit together and
hang out or have a dinner your family
who care about those people you don't
love your family that's a for when
someone like you love your kids or your
wife it's like no yeah yeah it's not
it's not like I went out of my way to be
like I really want to hang with these
people I have to yeah literally friends
like you write like a group of people
you meet with it there's nothing doesn't
exist like my friends in Chicago I get
jealous they have friends that they see
after work
yeah oh I got a you know what I can come
for 20 I have a lunch I gotta go to a
thing that's it everybody everybody here
is on their way somewhere they don't
have time to stop yeah yeah this is a
this is a transient city people moving
yes the one my one gripe about Los
Angeles zero community
nobody gets together and has like you
know do you know your neighbors I
actually do only because well because if
you if you didn't have to do when you
didn't have kids you drivers correct sir
no marker without children you don't
know anyone who you raised by [ __ ]
werewolf see I know my neighbors when I
was single I know my neighbors now yeah
Gavriel well but I know them well I
really well enough as May we're
neighbors first and last name the name
is large Indian family that's how you
refer to these people that is offensive
that is so rude in this climate
it's a large Indian there's a large
Indian franklin's banner roll his name
is Danny Danny in the Indian they're
moving out next week now the guy next to
me is literally 100 years old yeah see
no but but la it's just not the same
that's all it is I don't I love Los
Angeles it should those are the little
things so yeah although I walk my kids
to school today and the the crossing
guard knows every kid's name he's an
older guy he's like hey Ben
hey Dad Terrence it's the greatest thing
in the world it's so what do you want
what I talk about this a lot in my mind
when I get out of comedy and stuff when
I'm done with all this not or when they
just kick me out yeah I either want to
do like something like that like
crossing guard guy or like golf cars
you've got a golf course Marshall you
know just drive through that's cool I
speed it up I'm gonna be that guy that
guy or the crossing guard I want a
simple fun like just chill job I outside
before you have and I answer for that
outside with shade crossing beekeeper
that's no I wanna be can I be on I want
to be I want to be I want to be the boom
like theater direct plays in a prep
school and probably in the Northeast
where I can I can have a German Shepherd
wear tweed jackets and smoke up I know I
want to be a gem mine was real broad you
know exactly the address that you're
gonna want to be I feel like yours
pretty straight on to them I just want
those I don't know where it is but I
want something like that I don't know
where in the United States of the world
it is yeah hey if it was up to me I just
got back from Italy for three weeks I if
I could do it I would move to Italy live
on the live on the island of Capri and
just rent scooters there was an old man
in the Sounders yeah motorized or you
can do all this how fast you want to go
that's what he said as fast as it goes
he goes this one we take off the thing
you go right on the mountain I rented
the fastest scooter and I [ __ ] you not
at one moment I was actually scared for
my life how are we doing there living my
life see this is the problem with that
leg what do you
in there who books who books Italy I was
just going to living yeah work well what
you read no [ __ ] ha ho you're on
Italy I'm just trying to get out of my
I'm just trying to get out of my head
Andrew he's a young man yeah who held
are you 35 ok
same age 68 in life Heaton right Brendon
is he's got this that pro athlete now of
course what gets him going yeah is his
business like being an entrepreneur
comedy positive and work is the what
work he'll never take it off from
working out work work work is what
drives him positive and it's true that
he could use a little you get outage for
you title you need some units of me time
you take a little vacation you go to
Capri eat some great seafood let's stare
at some women in bikinis I want to live
on a working olive orchard yeah it's
very easy to settle now you say that you
asked me why I went to Italy I can do I
just did that you have that blew your
mind I got an airplane and took a
vacation so you what can you do well I
don't want to do that yes you do yeah
you do you want me to show you some
photos bring up Capri on there show him
the island of Capri they say company I
gripe with him as he never hangs out
anymore yeah why you do is with my
family I work so much I like I love my
house I just want to be home that's fair
now that's actually real like I don't
want to grab meals and that's where I
was whoa look at that that looks
ridiculous you see that little orange
canopy yep just miss just you and the
wife he went yeah yeah just chillin how
long - almost three weeks
Wow you see that water yeah it's blue
swam in it you can see all the way to
the bottom all the way to the bottom all
that likes like I'm not kidding about a
hundred yards out I know you put up with
my rent today
I rented a you know a snorkel Oracle
best best best thing I've ever done in
my life but here I am coffee small there
though yeah you just drink them all day
take a small Express you drink all day
well I grew up in that water you know
lived in Greece for three years as a boy
swimming in that water Italy my uncle
we lived in Rome that makes me my heart
hurts a little bit right doesn't that
make you feel like look what am i doing
when my lions yak me if I'm gonna be
moving Italians know how to live oh my
god they don't eat wait if you eat
dinner at eight out there they think
something's wrong with you yeah so what
time do they 10:30 at night oh yeah I
know that naps yeah they hang out yeah
we we we were like going we we met a guy
that has a restaurant he said what time
you want to come by cuz we were chatting
he was it he was so and like he was
intrigued he was like tell me what you
do here cuz how did you find this nook
or tesha this little part of Sicily that
we found he said so I tell me when you
want to come by I said I've come dinner
like you know 8:30 maybe 9:00 we got
something to do he goes nine o clock oh
my god oh my god I gotta stop prepping
now I was like what what time you want
me to come it goes I don't know eleven
eleven thirty you know hang hang for
with me you know like I'm like oh yeah
okay we go around there like 11:30 it's
just getting people are like in their
70s are like yeah we'll show up now do
they have to get up in the morning
though yep
yeah they yeah but they you know it maps
that I take a they hang out they take a
nap this hang their work days are like
go to work and they live to go home to
be a hundred and twenty-one years old
yeah they're the oldest people in the
world they kept their life has come and
go they don't go to computers and they
don't work now they get it they just fit
they figured it out somehow well so when
I'm 70 I'm gonna be bored if I need 20
years no you wouldn't
if you did that every day your life
you'd be pretty blossom you wake up in
the morning you take a little dip see do
right under that boat that's right
little dips you do if you get you wake
then you go back your stuff to push beat
it against the rocks yeah rip its legs
right I saw but that's your work at that
and that's your workout and your lunch
look at that boom-boom not open there
are eggs
jump in there are you get to work for
about an hour what's that that's it it's
typing oh yeah no typing they don't use
computers or they don't have any all
right poetry sometimes a Pablo Neruda of
yeah okay good cookie doesn't poems or
work orders it's in one of the other
they call it the big man the big man was
a fire
and then he says to his assistant send
and she sends it out and then it goes
done I gotta go and he and then he gets
on his scooter with no you know with no
regulator one top of the mountain has a
little glass of wine I'm sold man yeah
you get up that you get up to the top
and have a glass of wine and then a
coffee I went to bar Vitelli from the
Godfather you know yes one of the
coolest items in my bar Vitali is a bar
that they that they use in The Godfather
a real town in outside of it in Sicily
it's north of gordana's yeah but this
whole town it go to bar Vitali yeah it's
Arthur
no no but le VI te ll I or something
like that Barba telly Godfather there it
is there it is there it is Ernest ah
look at that okay that's shorter outside
there's got to be a better shot of like
the hole that's it I went there I sat on
that patio and had a little had a dapper
a dapper Tony how crazy and it kept in a
little cappuccino
it was nice dude it was just these babes
so these people these people these
people like loved wanting to know where
you're from they were fascinated that
you went up here dude most people that
go to Italy don't go to Sicily most
people who go to Sicily don't go to
these little cuz they don't get a lot of
tourists there it's all locals and stuff
it's just that's where you want to be
it's hard to get there you have to rent
a car you gotta go all the way up in the
mountain the roads are about the size of
your shoe you know which is like 15 and
a half thick you know I mean kid I can
feel it from here I didn't feel it when
he wears tight jeans like that dis ding
dong is like I don't think his ding dong
you go there's great so happy they want
to know where you're from they want to
know what you do were you driving the
scooter your wife is on the back we
rented a little fee for this we did a
Fiat Oh like a little yeah drop top I
got stuck twice got that attack attack I
just push it back and where are you
staying three staying when you're in
Italy little tiny spots all over Italy
like little tiny I'll say like Four
Seasons you're like wow we did a few
nice nice hotels in big town if you go
to Rome get a nice hotel yeah if you're
going a little tiny spot stay at a
little boutique hotel the boutiques are
sometimes more expensive yeah who gives
a [ __ ]
yep you went to Italy drops me whenever
somebody said listen when
somebody says like they're trying to
pick you cutting corners on vacation
your schmuck you don't have pinned my
qualification or tattoo or schmuck what
do you smell
yeah I like my people call round looking
for a deal attack yeah I got this piece
for nine bucks
I see it very good I can tell that's
what you do which I see nine whole
dollars on your head for what you and
your right a vacation should be you know
and I know this sounds this is rude to
say for people that don't have a lot of
money but you're rich okay if you can't
if you can't go don't go save some money
save it all online my Instagram then you
can enjoy the fun I had because you're
poor and you can't go stonehenge when
Abscam is free for you free I mean what
did you pan for three weeks last year
that spared zero expense how was that
that's honestly one of the best times in
my life when I wasn't that crazy what
what place I don't like yeah you know I
don't ever care to go back to France
ever again see I love French I can flush
French right down the toilet love France
and all the Parisians to you everyone
that lives in Paris you didn't have to
get out of here
why I went into I attitude everywhere we
went yeah
do you have an english-speaking here's
how soft my voice you see how loud I my
voice when I go into those place excuse
me do you have an english-speaking menu
attitude weird is my girl's whole family
literally her brother everyone went that
too is that they never go back same
thing never don't need a soul it's
gotten so bad and it was been so bad for
a long time that France Paris was
putting up billboards I'm sure you can
find them billboards telling Parisians
to be nicer be nice to tourists yes now
the reason I get by in Paris is because
I speak a little French and I try super
hard and no matter how hard I try I go
like this I go with Max I go excuse him
lush elemental and they go it's just
around there you go there yeah they
never speak to me afraid there won't do
me that cuz that what it says mrs. le
vide what does that mean come on let me
see is it one of those two down there
what would the what could those mean
wait let's find out what Ching googled
first would you Google Ching Paris
billboard there's no these nights are
the tourists
that's good innit yeah it is that's
pretty I mean you see I don't think our
gonna get a bottom right bottom left
bottom left what is that the I see I
what are those things
there's you know that's not it that
looks like oh that's be nice to old
people moving no it's saying if you want
ice this way I think it's C Maxie I took
French for four years in high school
please it's telling you to go somewhere
that's saying be nice to all no no it's
a it's a it's an ad for something anyway
listen
Parisians here's how I learned people
that were out people we were trying to
watch we were there doing like a Super
Bowl and we were trying to watch the
game for fun I was like wouldn't it be
fun to find a sports but we found one
they were all Outsiders for sure they
were all non Parisians they lived in the
front row
they hate Parisians I bet so the French
cannot stand people repair vice-versa
they hate each other and these people
were so nice and cool they love this we
taught them beer pong because they were
like they were like they need some he
was like no he was like will you teach
he wanted to know how to play it cuz we
were joking about it I said yeah you got
ping pong balls and they had like little
kind of like fake golf ball whatever
works so yeah we did at the bar they had
them I feel like I blessed them I feel
like you know when I feel like when when
a traveler like goes to a new land and
he gives them something in their culture
I gave them that
I feel like I blessed them a little bit
it was like just given the Indians fire
or smallpox same chance yeah I bless
them yes
wiped out our entire country culture but
yes I did a little favorite we didn't
give the Native Americans yeah I know
it's a joke
oh hi welcome yeah yeah hey so jump back
Japan the most fun most polite sweet
giving yes very nice wonderful people
but now you Godzilla when you walk
around there they all speak English
really well they all try yeah or use
Google Translate have you ever seen that
no you bring up the camera on your phone
you can put it up to a document and
it'll read it in Japanese to you there's
actually there's a device though you can
speak into it the same way gonna
translate the same thing it'll do it
I'll load the dictionary and I can say
hey how do I get to Shibuya station you
know I don't want to do a racist
impression right now it's not even good
Hyundais
nope not talking the samurais yeah good
I want someone to isolate that clip and
loop it over and over and over
maybe I love gems this is racist when
your vacation in Japan and Godzilla's
approaching there you go that's just
blatant racism at is it yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's funny racism it's not even
that funny though if you're funnier if
it said like when Godzilla comes to
steal your [ __ ] when you're in Japan or
something on I mean like that'd be funny
or if it's make a joke about why I'm my
god this is like Japan no Tokyo all over
Tokyo there's like 90 neighbourhoods to
go to Shinjuku Shinjuku is fondest [ __ ]
like this how's the food I mean I mean
okay you should start it how much I'm a
meat eater right so northern Japan is
more seafood
great it's delicious but let's be real
it's the same ocean we get the fish from
the same I'm not gonna play this game of
Japan the best sushi it was phenomenal
hungry then I have great Drive great
sushi here in California Nobu is pretty
good
it's it we have great sushi yes but
southern Japan take a high [ __ ] best
meat I've ever had in my life
no there is no American loser Wagyu yeah
so so so Kobe Kobe Wagyu let me teach it
let me quickly teach you some this
pretties we have Kobe cows in America in
the 70s the Japanese government signed a
deal with the United States saying you
may have Japanese cows why do you have
to call them American Wagyu you cannot
call it Japanese Wagyu what happens
today we still call it Japanese why it's
a lie you look how look how marvel that
is now that's not normal you can google
this animal 5% of restaurants in the
United States actually get real Japanese
Wagyu shipped over here the rest of them
removes your research huh well we ate it
I stumbled upon a I stumbled upon a
five-star Michelin restaurant I'm
telling you on accident we went to a
kabuki show closed where did you find
this online she goes hasn't been here in
two years we started walking through
Kyoto there's little neighborhood I'll
show you photos we found a restaurant on
Act's I said look how cute that looks
17 people inside little tiny tables I go
to the guy hey could we eat here he goes
oh no no no no good reservation I was
like no no no the chef comes out starts
talking finds out
from Chicago I was from Colorado he
studied the molecular science of beef in
Denver she's great molecular science of
beef so because of this connection he
says you go get a highball a whiskey
highball up the street at the bar come
back when we close I'll serve you photos
this guy sat with us for hours champagne
wine whatever we want he just wanted to
talk to us because he couldn't believe
we found this plate it was come we
shouldn't have in them you know crasher
yeah crapload is an understatement I
crashed my ship for the Japanese it was
unbelievable is everything like yeah
it's not about quantity like just you if
you if you served you had 17 people at
your table there's a sushi place in LA
called sushi Park have you been there
when - yeah up on the it is it's so
ridiculous it's like I don't know how
many table tops but they're open
basically from 12:00 to 2:00 yeah yeah
yeah you're either in there you're not
see yeah there's like flat five tables
yeah and it's just it's all about the
quality you don't order anything you
just trouble mikasa yeah that's what I
say you just get what they get yeah so
then you went on this Kobe beef rampage
and came back to the States and we're
just kind of you're kind of like
whistleblower now I don't like when they
lie so I'm the guy that whistle blows
yeah so be beef whistle when it says
Japanese why do I go okay prove it prove
it prove it take cuz you know what they
do in Japan you know what they do in
southern Japan if it's a if it's the
highest grade why do they show it to you
first before they cook it bring it out
on a plate raw to a niche and know you
approve it like it's wine like you go
you know it's a little taste they go if
you smell it you can look at it look at
out marble why is this so Marco because
well it's a breed of cow first of all
that the reason that they're like this
right this is like championship breeding
imagine like how horses you know I mean
it's like yeah someone's I got bought a
horse and you're like yes there's a
horse unless it's a championship
bloodline this bloodline of cow and the
region in which they're raised which is
the Kolbe a region is why they're so
rich what does that look like see this
town so by the way beautiful cows is
what I've read their scene look what
I've read about Kobe beef is that they
are it's not a good life for the cow the
cow is not really allowed to move look
at how black they are cows not really
allowed to do the right correct me if
I'm wrong if you didn't like that you
did like I said look at how black they
are go like black sorry they're not
white cows job he'd rather have a white
cow
can we show him a white
no wait wait that's one there let me
just see the rest of them change scroll
down I'm saying look at how beautiful
their Co they're shiny because those
aren't those aren't Co baby no that's a
short Kobe cows I believe are kept
sometimes that him they're from even
moving all right are you yes that's why
I dragged you there oh it's black the
coats are like horses they're it's like
beautiful damn he's cool looking but
they're not allowed to really move much
right in they're kept in like smaller
areas right they're not fun but if I
feel they're fed extremely rich high fat
diets but when it's watered but when
they kill them they kill them like
slaughter do we hang them upside down
into life I've been to slaughterhouses
in the Midwest why do we go because in
the Midwest like it's a part of our team
the most interesting how you become an
adult in the Midwest you got to go see a
slaughter farm as a kid you got to go
check it out you see how you get your
food at school that's that to school
that's like a part of life you see how
whole corn gets [ __ ] pulled off the
husk you see how a cow gets killed in a
chair he's not get problem here here we
go with look at how beautiful that is
so they of reckoning look at they but
they treated like a god look at I put a
marching number on it look at it look
out a middle the sword neither crowd for
they cut it's like it's like imagine
before they killed you if they cheered
that'd be nice that'd be nice
yeah they're likely about to die and
you're like well thank you girls
that's an expensive cow the meat on that
cow is alright God you know okay go back
down look at that there's a photo right
there keep going keep going keep going
why goo look at that why goo American
Kobe click on that how about the fact by
the way why did they write Y goo and
then put you have any symbols in them
right in American Kobe that they didn't
need to do that look at the difference
in the in the look of the meat I know
one is like delicious no no the one on
the left the one on the left
I when I ate his kids his why you fork
yeah didn't they give you a knife but I
think it's a joke a really nice knife
like a hand-carved knife it's never been
used so when I had the real Kobe beef in
Japan yeah my they shaved it paper-thin
and you would take it and put it in
boiling water and eat it
different different different out there
that would ruin it I've know what you're
talking about is oh that's really you're
at a Korean Barbarina this was it did
you just try one up in his rally with
your Arabic you story where you want
South Korean you were in Sawtelle
correct correct
listen listen really all right what you
did what you did was Korea Japan
sometimes considered a shabu shabu is
what you did but I was taken to the
apparently isn't that shabu shabu isn't
that what hot yes that's a bad shot but
I was thinking I'm a fool I asked them
whatever question guys no I know but in
general
Brendan is the one that wrote that down
there but that's just wrong that doesn't
even say anything large Indian family
family dan dan gel a large Indian man
yeah you did shabu shabu that's what
that is
he knew me for this is true story yeah
you knew me for a good more clothes yeah
we're close yeah and we know everything
about each other
and he goes my wife is and then this is
um twice there you go are you [ __ ] Mela
I just for the reasons not clicking but
I get you blacked out huh I get it Bauer
did you apologize profusely I slapped
her you got a hit or how else are they
gonna learn to say your name to me every
time I see you let's talk about that I I
don't know anybody's name and I feel bad
about it all the time and more people I
meet through comedy but but they say
your brain can only hold her around 300
news the Dumbarton who kiss certain
people's remembers everybody's me I know
he goes up to people and he says hi I'm
Tom and he said I'm Brendan he goes
Brandon bold Brendan is bold Brendan's a
bold man remembers that I knows the name
game but he also has like a thing in his
ear people telling them he does he
he's got Scientology in his head yep not
just John Tyrell he does I've had a
little interaction with it 150 I what
secularism and vases without a prompt
yeah it's hundred fifty it's called the
Dunbar number faces for sure I remember
I don't forget a face they thought I
would say say to repeat them yeah but I
was like hi I'm Brian can see you Brian
you know a game where you put a place
you put um you put an association in a
place in it so so guys who can remember
you know there's a book called
moonwalking with Einstein about like he
won some memory competition there's an
actual technique where you put you
create sort of a place like a house and
you put whatever you in your head yes so
whatever you want to sounds easy it's it
actually is so you can seven but you can
learn you can learn these guys to do
these Mary games can learn like
literally a thousand numbers in sequence
and they just they use their body the
one would go on the on their pinky they
put it in a place with an association
it's a really there's a technique to do
memory how much I think he put me build
a house yes you build a place you build
so so it's like how people remember pie
how do people remember pie you know
people 3.46 how do they do that you just
see it so many times there's an actual
technique there's an actual technique do
you one of these guys yes I read the
book - it's called um there's a it goes
way back to 3,000 you think okay so
maybe so lately I've been thinking I'm
dumb like I because I know I'm pretty
smart guy but then I like Rubik's Cube I
tried to do it I tried I was like I'm
gonna buy it and learn cuz I see people
do it it makes me jealous just doing
this three technique three days threw it
away
not if someone wow if you looked online
how did I do they did three days through
the web go into it yeah so do you know
if you heard us bought a bunch of new
books sat on the airplane a couple pages
do not but because they you weren't
interested in them this book I do the
same thing how about buy a book I'm like
dude I should learn about this subject
gone or page that relevant then up a
book on something I'm super into I will
[ __ ] fly through yeah it's not
relevant to use because you don't have
to do it and that if someone was like
hey we want you to play Kurt Cobain in
the
next movie and they gave you this
[ __ ] thick book and you had a chance
to be Kurt Cobain you're gonna knock
that out can I tell you something you're
got the role I would lie I would say I
read it yeah and I would lie my way to
college I would lie the whole thing have
you ever bet you have you heard of the
myelin sheath the idea that so so when
people are really good at say tennis
right yeah or they're really good at
whatever it might be they actually did
all the neurons that fire together you
you will literally create sort of not
only sort of what you can actually
physically see like a almost a fatty
sheath a layer that will go over the
neurons so how are you holding your hand
like because it's literally like you'll
get these now you'll get these pathways
in your brain that actually physically
form around up there it is right there
around a movement around so if you're
tennis or tennis players can you will
have a predictable so they're my Iranian
sheath is the part of the brain that was
that is connected to that movement and
so any kind of practice a piano players
you know master piano players or
whatever if you do it for long enough
your brain literally will change the
synapses and neurons will sort of create
almost like a pipeline because you've
done it so much but yes and that's why
they tell you to take fish oil and
things because the myelin sheath is
essentially fat it's it's a you know
omega-3 to come derivatives of different
kinds of fatty acids I guess so when you
take fatty acids it actually I'll take
your shirt a little fish oh that's still
can't remember most I see because it's
not relevant not at all but I think it's
also hereditary I think more people are
prone to having a brain that's better
that's that's better at certain things
my I can tell you I I can leave anything
anywhere and I can know where I left it
anywhere ever yeah if I left the key at
your house two years ago I know exactly
where I left it my geographical brain is
remarkable I don't need to use maps most
the time I just figured it out I own the
worst I have the worst seat it's funny
cuz most of my friends are the app
they'll go how do you know this place I
go I went here once if I pass that once
you do register in childhood I don't
know I feel like that's most people a
lot of time remember certain things my
childhood oh I got a bunch of people in
my life that remember when they
five right but what are they doing now
if the good question one of them is my
driver that's actually pretty smart
yeah it's a good driver he's outside
right now and I make him wait make him
sit and wait I say you think about your
childhood while I'm inside because it's
so I don't you should see what I didn't
know you had a drive you have a lot of
money reiver plural I've drivers I don't
have one drive you mean to all of them
no there's one girl that I like but the
two guys piss me off every day they
didn't do it like they didn't do
anything I don't you know what they're
up to what this coffee order was wrong
my driver coffee ronk threw it in his
face as I go get me another one burn his
face it's iced coffee but yeah I threw
the iced coffee and in and it knocked
out one of his contacts ice cube knocked
out of his contact oh he's crying in
them in the parking lot of Starbuck you
know yeah I'll go get it
okay go get it I pass save this wear an
eye patch [ __ ] hey like dude don't
you feel like we hang out if I carry
last time I did when you hang out some
from college or high school and I can go
over like certain day's events I'm like
gone it's because I haven't thought
about that or because they're living in
it
they still they want it because they
love that like that was the important
time than where you've gone on to do
whatever when somebody says remember
when we gotta get nervous every time we
do it man man oh man oh six was the
first time like you remember the month I
don't have like you're like that girls
like oh no tell me the year tho that
those things happen like I I don't pay
attention even the year I get nervous
right as you're moving everything
bringing things up here bring it up like
this somewhat my my booking agent the
other day what month did you play xmi Z
oh dude oh God I get in my calendar as a
joke to myself I go I think it was May
look it up I'll throw December 6th you
know I mean like I I'll throw your
stuffing out there so don't sound like
you're completely losing May when were
there May and Oh 8 dude I said they said
how long my life and I they said how
long we lived here and I went seven
months I think and my wife went we've
been here for two years
are you serious I was like yes seven
months times a few yeah we've been in a
bunch of seven
I know I'm just saying overall I got a
jurist i've been settled in for seven
month two years now my daughter was like
oh five days my wife goes 12 days yeah
okay yeah yeah but that's semantics
that's semantics yeah kids a that's a
good but then certain things I tell you
Geographic your things certain things
I'm like keyed in on I'm so good with
landmarks I couldn't I can tell you
username cross streets I can tell you
all the landmarks are that crossed yeah
I probably tell you the store that's on
there yeah but this mapping buddies we
remember what you remember you have way
more inhibitive synapses in your brain
so things that that are reminds you of
danger so what you'll do they think the
whole city's a danger to me left in the
right hemisphere they think is so the
right hemisphere is the hemisphere that
goes basically imagines all that could
be wrong and dangerous about a situation
right sit over there your left brain
goes hold on and your left brain will
continue to will actually control the
right brain say stop stop let me think
about this and the left brain will we'll
go through all the scenarios and
actually say this was that's ridiculous
there are no monsters there's another
and it'll create an approximation of
what reality is so the left brain so why
does he remember streets and man because
I had a lot of what you remember is you
grow up in trombone or listen you
remember the things that are bad you
remember the things that are bad and you
avoid them so it's way easier remember
[ __ ] that went wrong or that was your
body's protecting and that's why I
remember negative things better than
exact happy that's why when a thousand
people came to a show and everybody
liked you and then one guy in the front
was like you're like [ __ ] I know that
guy's face I know I know is the favorite
count of a facial hair on it and I heard
some I forget which comic just by on
Meryl it's a man all the time but he was
saying he or no his Greg Fitzsimmons
unbroken he was saying stuck he's the
best but he was saying how same thing
like our brains are triggered towards
that that one guy who's not having a
good time like you there be a thousand
faces before the reason it it zeroes in
on that and focus on that one he had
it's very weird it just saw activity by
why can't everybody come like why are
you in the front row doing but you know
what it just lasts sometimes people do
that though there's one be entertained
sometimes they just don't laugh I don't
laugh when I'm really entertained
oh I don't laugh ever I try to laugh i
watch if I really like a comic up I'll
be more marveling and I'm nothing it but
I'm not laughing when I watch
Ghostbusters as a kid there's a funniest
movie I've ever seen when I was a kid I
was I would I've never been more insane
you know what I was doing I was biting
my nails my girlfriend patty patty we
used to always say Brian calm down
because I would watch John Leguizamo
when he was doing his one-man shows when
I was younger and I'd be like this and I
wanted to be a comic or something I
wanted to do what he did and instead of
laughing I was so entertained that I
really liked this and my girlfriend go
stop biting your nails to keep because
it would made me how old were you when
you I wasn't even 21
I still Bob you do too oh yeah you do
nerve I bite my nails if I'm thinking if
I'm nervous I'm overwhelmed like this is
so short right now I'm just about a
hundred times in a minute when I get
nervous
me too I starts at my bladder just like
get it out go I come you just start
coming when you get nervous
yeah what a bad sugar negativity bias
how about Louie CK coming up at the
cellar woody no we talked we talked
about it a little bit a little bit town
I want to say this through this no no no
here's my okay I'll give my two super
student to stupid sense cuz every comics
to like take in there you're bothering
me about yesterday first of all I didn't
even hear about it until like the
afternoon until like a million people
had asked to attentions yeah yeah and
then I got on Twitter which is a garbage
dump of a place now Twitter can [ __ ]
drown I think it's the worst place in
the world it sucks really it's dog [ __ ]
now it's not even fun anymore I used to
be fun wow so many comics were taking
shots at Lois and any big-name comic
film well Michael Ian Black actually
actually stood him defended him but then
recanted all that because he got hit so
he knew he was gonna get hit got too
much backlash but then that's why he
defended him yeah but what he should
have done because he said in there I
know I'm gonna face some backlash from
this he should just tweeted it and
disappeared yes
get off yeah if you're gonna but he went
back and because his audience his
audience is very much the audience I
would put him in check very left-wing
hundreds and they're very like are you
kidding me right now yeah versus look at
that Michael Ian Black
yeah firestorm yeah here's my other
thing okay so that there's articles
written you know in in like
maybe the HuffPo or whatever variety
we're now smaller publications but like
the of this ilk and like Ian Karmel
Julian McCullough a couple other comics
they were like this is a workplace issue
this is disgusting if you jerked off at
a Dunkin Donuts he got fired your boss
wouldn't hire you back five months later
if he made doesn't ask glazed donut in
the world he depends on how good you are
with the sprinkles he made the best the
world when I let him come you guys went
after him and here's my thing all I want
to say is I think what okay what Louis
did was wrong right I am also not I am
also not a perfect human being I'm not
about to be up here throwing stones at
Louie Louie can deal with his issues in
his way and I'm not the one to go you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you better not
come back you think this is enough time
I don't have time for that in my psyche
to go I should be the guy also throwing
stones no I don't need to throw stones I
don't know you can if you want to I
think it's a [ __ ] weird thing to do
but it's not my business and I don't I
don't necessarily like or dislike the
guy sound like I'm I'm like in love with
the guy here's a better example I just
comedy I think he's brilliant just
saying like Fox not a personal I don't
have a personal give you a better
example Aziz Ansari okay I have nothing
against that guy I don't think he I
don't think he's funny he's not my brand
of comedy that's fair good for him do
his thing when he got caught up on his
thing I can tell abraded I defended know
I was like that guy didn't do nothing
wrong he was a bad date right yeah he
was a bad day great yeah but but but
again no dog in the race no you're so
same thing with Louie like I don't have
a personal relationship with a guy I
just think I'm not gonna be the one to
throw stones because what do I gain from
what do i what would I gain from that
being the one that's like on Twitter
going you're deserve to come those
people yet talk about it most people
react they get traffic especially what
Michael Ian Black said look it he didn't
say anything conscious but people have
to be allowed to serve their time and
move on with their lives I don't know if
it's been long enough or his career will
recover or if people have him back hey
that was hey controversal it's like a
kindergarten statement it's like hey and
maybe you might be able to color blue
Michael you know a little more effort
into it but I thought he was gonna I
thought he like said something
controversial no he didn't but this is
my problem is like then people [ __ ]
SiC the dogs on you in black and it's
like but now you bothered they won now
he bounced down so my whole thing is I
don't like when people are self-serving
like when they do this thing when they
go it's like everybody became a fan of
Joe Biden you know there's so many
people who probably [ __ ] loathed him
and his platforms then he dies they're
like [ __ ] was American hero and you're
like no you mean a trauma came John
McCain Joe Biden also died this morning
[Laughter]
he went down in a plane with a
helicopter dude he was doing a stunt I
don't know what you write but I read my
thing sexy but like people are saying
like excuse me scroll back up chin very
first once should they're like oh what
time did he serve I'm confused what time
did he serve well he lost his
development and shows with FX so he lost
millions of dollars there he lost his
special with with whoever he was with
he's lost a ton of stuff says what work
has he done to right his wrongs whereas
the proof that you learn anything who
says he ever stopped harassing women
what are you talking about
here see here's the problem with this
but she doesn't know but this is an ill
argument because we don't know that's
what I'm saying nobody knows did Louis
did he go to read I'm not the face is
what I don't have it and he ruined these
women's careers and stuff that's I don't
but also and I'm not condone at all what
he did what he did was was we had it was
ways weird but there's levels to this
assault sexual assault game sure there's
one to five jack on from a woman who
goes back to your hotel late at night
would probably be a one on my scale
right being a five rapes only five what
was fun one two five one two five
weird scale I thought it was 10 no no I
always think 10 I know I go one two five
so what if I tell CNN does it whatever
see bones I think I think there's a
there's a fundamental difference I think
there's a fundamental who's in touching
someone against their will
touching physically yeah and I'd hold
them hostage was your class speaking to
somebody being naked in front of a door
which is actually a form of kidnapping
maybe that's [ __ ] up that's a that's
[ __ ] up you you can you can make there
there are there is criteria to break
this down
saying those rules - yeah but here's
what I'm saying I just don't like
self-service when you're looking for
retweets and likes because you know it's
upon so this is a lot of if you have an
issue with what Louie did and you have
an issue with how much time he spent
apologizing or not apology not making up
for his wrongs
that's on you I just from a personal
standpoint if I'm not a one that I don't
need to throw that stone and I see
people do it and I'm like if it's
self-serving it's it's it's not captain
save-a-ho either like that's not it it's
Mass virtue signaling isn't yeah virtue
singing up there like who else wants to
gang up on nice that was [ __ ] up let's
do it I'll be the first one retweets
likes yeah it was people if you're a
comic in New York and you don't agree
with what the seller did don't go up the
cellar if you're such a badass but
here's the thing is also like that's not
the sellers fall like this whole thing
the seller said the the owner the Comedy
Cellar had a statement that was
essentially saying in so many words I'm
not gonna dictate whether or not Louie
can and when Louie can come back there's
no time scale so that's up to the
audience if the gnome is all about that
know him horns to come yes but he also
he was sleeping and goes I woke up to in
the middle of the night it was the
middle of the night Louie came on did a
surprise say who's obviously broke up
the in the morn was like even he does
why didn't you come back this soon I
think this is a little soon but that's
what he wants to do the audience has a
choice to walk in say that Louis okay in
this environment I don't know but in
this environment I would say that if
Louie wants to get up on stage this less
than a year after all he missed an
ovation he's gonna get yep he's gonna
get he's gonna take both heat and praise
let's gonna come no matter what and if
he wants to stick to his guns I believe
that in this environment louis c.k could
just start from now and keep doing
stand-up take all the heat it will die
down and he'll be back to selling out
theaters so he could sell later right
now he's selling arena you could
immediately put out a special tomorrow
instead I want to talk about if he if he
did a TED talk and said this won't be
funny but I just want to talk about it
for two hours so the whole world would
to agree yeah I mean in my opinion you
should he but they all said but to a
justify devil's advocate what Louie
should have done if I'm being honest
from from the way he handled it I think
right he first of all you should have
said [ __ ] sorry straight up he should
have amended his he should have
with these women and gone what can I do
to move us forward in the future to be
kind of like a leader in it then it
would have like helped but instead of
just going my bad that you saw my penis
I understand I have power I gotta go
it's not a good way to go a little well
drag me as a very generous nice guy I
don't know how to say this is my other
thing we don't know that's my problem
I wish I know you know people who know I
know people don't know until I know
myself
yeah I don't know him I don't know if
that's a good point I don't know I know
people think you're a dick or rogue in
the Dacre no but people think he's a
bigger dick for sure - right
yeah do say that yeah no I just mean um
you know I'm safe I don't take that in
if when people always a bad doing like
all right well what happened because a
he's very successful
so with that success comes jealousy like
a mother people hate other people yeah
the more the better you are they do had
a little experience and I have been
around him yeah way before he was famous
he trusted my neighbor I I used to walk
by his house every day and here in LA
yes nice to see him see him almost every
day I knew was mean to you um he is a he
is a bristly prickly guy did he say
hello Brian ever no holy [ __ ] that's
okay but he knew who you were no I don't
know I mean I hit again I've been in
groups and Lizzie no I'm not saying this
night I don't want to get into I don't
want to get into your his neighborhoods
I don't want to say I don't like him it
I don't want to say that he's a dick I'm
not saying that what I mean is that from
the amount of time and it's limited yeah
I've been around him yeah and by the way
in a periphery way whether it's standing
in a group while he's talking with other
people whether it's people who've worked
with him very closely very closely and
know him knew him for many many years
and had long talks with those people one
of which was recent he is a complicated
guy sure which is also technically he's
also got a dark side like we all do he's
got it and I guess from was I should run
in a machine I guess from what I've been
around him from what I have in my
experience in comes well it's not
surprising and that I think I can make
an
I think you could say that he has more
darkness in many ways than light and
it's not surprising that he would be
that he would come back after a year and
not so much worried about the heat his
day but let me ask you guys this what
would what do you think would make these
me to movement people happy what what
does he well this is it's two years no
no I'm just not tired should he lose no
your rides and show right it's not it
run a number of time on a scale it's
it's it's is it was his approach they
wanted when my assumption is they wanted
him to be more vocal about his complete
that would have made them happy and and
well I think it I think it would have
helped I don't know I don't think Keith
I don't think there's an I paid a big
price let's be paid a big price millions
of dollars and special and other stuff
but that money is erroneous for them
it's more like they want to know that he
did he reached the next step to going
hey I gotta fix some problems for sure
publicly - I need to apologize these
people that I hurt I need to go out of
my way to find out a way to do we know
did he do that behind the scenes because
we wouldn't know cuz no one talked about
it they wouldn't talk about it right I
mean some of those girls they scrub
their social media and they disappeared
right like I think the damage was pretty
bad for a lot of those women very bad
you know I'll get attacked for saying
that was somewhat bad yeah but I'm just
saying like what he did like he just
needed to approach it I joked about on
stage a while about his letter I said
dude he said he said the word [ __ ] or
dick dicker [ __ ] I was like those are
that's a heavy word yeah sorry you saw
my [ __ ] never showed my dick he's a dick
sorry I'm sorry I showed my dick but
Dickinson's I apologize for exposing the
weird part about that is a lot of the
women he word he didn't he did this with
we're co-workers like comics fellow
comics
yeah like gals who are like you know I
mean like what are you doing bro like
like people that you're working with
that's a very strange thing that's no I
think by this day I feel like things
going on here there are two things any
City right here a story like that when I
hear a story like that I feel like there
are two words I could use one is rage
and the other is narcissism
I think that he's a he probably has a
he's a pretty narcissistic guy or
and full of rays to do that and that
that's that's a I've said this on stage
and I'll say it in here too because I
don't know if I'll ever talk about it
again cuz I'm tired of it but um America
loves art but they don't want to know
where it comes from
Louie if you go back yeah look at all
the bits he does look at all the [ __ ] he
constantly talks about jerking off and
being weird with women dude his whole
show is about his discomfort with women
no his movie this was can I know I know
that got cancelled was all about so my
point is America loves this art right
every audience member all these people
that are against him now when they did
love him he told you that he was weird
he told you he was odd with women and we
applauded it's ready to come I'm just
saying when we find out the truth
we've we get weird you know rogue we get
uncomfortable like and I say that Amy
Winehouse that girl she got famous here
after she was famous in Britain her most
famous song here was they tried to make
me go to rehab and I said no no no and
then when she died a heroine we were
like oh how because she [ __ ] told you
I have a massive issue we celebrated
he's singing for help we love
celebrating issues Rogan just had on the
guy who wrote Fight Club
Michael Chino a corner by the way I'm
great writer and he was talking about
how a lot of his writing is is banned
and prison space just found like yeah
his writing is banned in prisons because
it's so stimulating oh yeah and also
he's been kicked out of writer group a
lot of writer groups and Rogen and he
were talking about the fact that his
writing is dark bland and he said and he
said but part of the human experience
like we were talking about dark and
light and if and good art good art
disturbs oh my god kind of goes a [ __ ]
man maybe it disturbs us because it
reminds us of our dark side of the side
we'd like to stare at court and all of
us have it yep we all have a serial
killer in us we all have a saint in us I
mean I really think that we as human
beings you occupy the full spectrum of
evil too
angelic behavior and if you don't if
you're not honest with yourself about
that and I think a lot of times art
brings that to the fore and some people
can't face it and they kick you out of
the writing group and I don't think you
could have interesting art without
license to export now that doesn't mean
you jerk off in front of people and I
mean you don't know the price but let's
go back to make sure that's not what
we're saying you know what the truth of
what we're saying is oftentimes we
celebrate art that comes from a very
dark place and when we don't like to pay
attention to where a comes from yeah
there's a van Gogh cut off his [ __ ]
ear yeah pretty clear he's a psycho or a
chick for he was crazy dude he was
clinically out of his brain he's still
considered to be company here's another
diffuse' mentally disturbed deranged
human being who is disgusting
we like to celebrate these people like
they're all perfect no dude deranged do
you guys think of this so so there's a
lot of talk on the left especially but
in general that if you're a bad person
yeah your art is now [ __ ] too so so a
lot of red they don't so whether or not
Woody Allen whether or not it's true
that Woody Allen's molested his
stepdaughter yeah there's this this
thing there are people his movies I
don't watch his movies his movies [ __ ]
his movies they're fun you can separate
the man from the art do I don't think so
like I wouldn't like if I found out that
I don't like I'm not enough huge fan of
his anyways but if you I found out
you're molesting kids well then I don't
want partake in anything you're doing it
does it but it doesn't mean he's not
good at being a director no it means
what about his so his movies so the
founding fathers like they own slaves
right but they wrote the Constitution
which is giving us the longest standing
democracy in the world but at the time
that was the that was the invite but I'm
just saying that you can't if I found
out Trump has slaves now I'm like what
the [ __ ] he does saying Yeah right done
yeah he does time to different but I do
thought saying with Woody Allen if he
didn't molest his stepdaughter yeah yeah
I'm not buying taking you next movie I
don't give a [ __ ] well it's better than
molesting your daughter daughter all
right we'll be right back I know it's
not a cut and dry case I don't know it's
so hard to go okay look like a what's a
good example of somebody who's like like
it like um I'm trying to get a good
example of someone who's like committed
something kind of [ __ ] up and then
like Chris Brown okay that's it okay
here's a great example that's a great
example here's the guy who beat the
[ __ ] life out of a girl publicly well
she beat his ass dude we carry on yeah
look um I come I come I come I come on
he put the girl in the hospital her face
fell apart yeah she better shoot his
feet yeah yeah yeah yeah dad a Humpty
Dumpty that girl there the [ __ ] chair
face is that really true yes No shut up
Bryan I didn't follow this you don't
know Chris Brown beat the [ __ ] outta me
I don't know you beat the [ __ ] hold on
hold on
ya know it's 2012 I didn't know Bryan
town has no idea about I really didn't
hop culture related ever yeah no he's
right here oh no dad why this is why
it's career kind of like he's never had
a number one like album since this now
I'll be selling out arenas still no he
does features now but he's never had
since the since the ones found this out
they've never found I didn't know he was
a piece of [ __ ] I didn't know that
that's it that's a piece of [ __ ] that I
[ __ ] that guy I can't believe that
makes me angry
here was this that Brian did to her oh I
didn't know he Harvey Oswald a piece I
didn't know I was dealing with a coward
piece of [ __ ] little [ __ ] like that why
do people even listen to him at all be
honey you I like that you just throw
beating 2013 Brianna
so what 2013 over 25 years off beat his
ass right now okay so the point the
point is has a lot of female fans of
course huns
million so two serial killers they get
married in jail they took people on the
outside that like I don't love them war
machine just got married
what dozen that's right no way no way
Google that Jen war machine marriage
who's the girl I don't know this happens
all the time
what's that called though there's a
syndrome it's well yeah but women women
age to Pentel get huge look at that's a
lovely photo sorry no can they can't and
they can't no conjugal visits they came
in [ __ ] so you bet yeah just pen pals
found engaged 230 here's the thing with
Chris Brown so and playing devil's
advocate so him in Rihanna young they
have this horrible relationship where
there that she's hitting him he's
sitting yeah that's what that was a
thing beautiful a she be sick
she bit his finger off anyways and his
dick so but they go back and forth and I
was pointing a finger though yep pointer
so so it's not now his pointer is
shorter than his pinky yes he got two
pinkies on one hand yeah I didn't know
so they go back and forth longhand and
then that was how many five years ago
yeah and they said he's gone through
rehab he hasn't really hit anyone since
even though it isn't anyone since that's
what they say even though some girl
clumsy did wait you know how you know
how you know and you second chances well
everyone everything I don't want to come
to hitting women really did you see her
face I mean that's a devil wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute this is
again this is not black and white a
physical abuse situation whatever that
was you're telling me he never deserves
to have a second chance in life
I don't know can't be around me in
entertainment I don't want him around me
I'm just saying I'm just saying why
don't one where I'm like dude he family
punches that's punches I know mother
yesterday I'm noting offending him they
were straight fifth fighting I don't
know man I don't know what [ __ ] maybe
she's a nightmare but I don't know man
no no I rematch I've been pretty mad
I've been a lot of relationships with
some crazy I'm not no one hears
condoning saying well what did she say
like no one's saying that I would you
know I didn't want to know what a
headlock and hold her down how about
that yeah you know what I'm saying but
when you start whaling on somebody if
that's my sister I'm gonna take your
[ __ ] head yeah I'll murder you murder
your head off yeah if my sister five
years late and you'd like kill I and the
bride's like you know why's no I don't
we've been together a hundred oh I've
been in rehab for the last five years
I've donated so much [ __ ] I just found
out about what you did five years ago to
my sister you know why you did this you
picked her up from the hospital what
happened oh my god told me am i have a
loop or what I knew they got in a fight
I didn't know he did that I don't want
did you hear the Joe Biden died crying
[Applause]
Wow all right sorry everybody
sorry that it's 2018 and I'm just coming
to no I think this is kind of nice that
you're not that you don't know yes this
is nice yeah it's fine it's fine
the point is he still has a lot of
[ __ ] fans at on a fancy sells out
stars that here's the thing
look this is kind of the same thing with
with a louis c.k okay demanding I was I
apologize tone was absurd look up his
tour louis c.k doing what chris brown
did are to complete again there's
there's levels right right yeah but also
without two talented guys who create a
demand in the respective fee have a
finished this so so but but what do
Chris pound did is worse I believe way
why am I not on the same planet thank
you okay just round it is about Oh exact
no event interesting there you go the
right events but why don't we but guys
but see sex is interesting
you jerk of him from so many people want
you dead forever you beat the [ __ ] out
of somebody like that which i think is
way worse it's way worse I don't think
anyone are you that big but but but but
but he has he comes back and he's better
than that right well because of his
talent well okay but also named Sony
Harvey Weinstein's really tell upcoming
event not roots I am NOT nicer one of
the best of all time all time lately but
also what he did like we can find
someone to do what he does yeah and
replace who's that who everyone oh i
blanked out what he did was so bad and
he to it took it it like Chris Brown is
being given Rihanna work cuz she's
[ __ ] them and he's raping but I think
what Chris Brown does beat the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of somebody I don't think
Harvey wants never did that up you I
raped somebody that suggest you read
multiple rape allegedly right I'm glad
your job alleged well no it's pretty I
mean he's funny he's a rapist yeah he's
always a PA he's he's a piece of [ __ ]
but I'm saying but I'm saying with Chris
Brown louis c.k same thing with that
dunkin donuts guys if you made the best
chocolate glazed donut in the world
you're gonna get a second chance way
faster anyone else you just gotta move
to another country to make donuts yeah
but so so you gotta go you gotta go
somewhere else to make donuts you got it
i think that's what people really wanted
him to do i think people wanted him to
just get the [ __ ] out of the united
states which I heard a rumor that he was
living in London or something like this
ek yeah somebody said he was living in
London and was not in New York anymore
they wanted him to go away for whatever
time
apologize in such a big grandiose way
like in such a big like own a tuxedo a
shirt on I don't know what you sure I
don't know man I've never [ __ ] jerk
off in front of women's and then got in
trouble for so I don't know what the
answer is but I think like I think they
just wanted a show yeah oh there was
something you should have [ __ ] showed
something something not just come back
to the cellar like my bad Ben got a year
yeah like can you imagine what I'm not
looking for a time line here I I think
in a lot of ways the fact that he had
two daughters the factory had to face
this massive public humiliation people
are losing millions of dollars to me
that's a large price to pay to get a
flat but that's all personal issues for
him they're saying you've done nothing
for these victims you've learned nothing
you've lost millions of dollars that's
what I'm saying what's the answer
yeah that's right people don't care
people who think I'm like I lost money
people like dude you're worth 50 no one
gives a [ __ ] you didn't just go on
Twitter family has hurt people like too
bad you hurt a lot of other families
saying he's paid a price in that sense
personally though yeah he hasn't done
anything for the overall I don't think
you could do first-rate good eat - I
don't even think those women I don't
think would make it better if he was
like I'm really sorry I mean you don't
think just a slip 10 million dollar
check I don't know it's not it's not
it's not for them as much as it is for
the pub the greater to humbly movement
ah that's what people want I'm just
saying like you want a Jess and Bobby I
think they're never gonna be happy like
let's say Lucy James okay for 2000 half
of my half my income is gonna go to this
let me tell you something fund if he did
a special if he did this Ted special
that I'm talking about her whatever he's
gonna do the next thing buzz he donated
every single dollar of it to a thing
people would slowly this that it would
just like whoop it would start to he's
gonna come back he's gonna have course
but it's bad Americans we love a second
act we love Redemption it and I and I
think that's a overall I think that's a
pot even when you fail again we still
alike come on you want to come one more
time we'll let you back here I think I
think overall yeah yeah we all we all
cuz I think we all inherently know that
all of us are flawed and that all of us
Robert Downey jr. yeah I don't know
there's ever been a greater story of
like he's on watch me bounce back so big
I'll be the biggest movie star after you
[ __ ]
you want me gone here's the other thing
somebody somebody was talking to me
about this over the phone and I think we
should move on to something else because
[ __ ] I just it's exhaust hose what
your friend said though he said he said
he said you know what's interesting
sex was at play at this sex was the crux
of this whole thing right second the
weird the weird gray area of like sexual
interactions between private people
behind closed doors he goes if he was an
addict if this was about drugs or
alcohol I guarantee you this story would
have been more felt by people they would
have gone on these really good shoes
you're doing it to yourself nice to
somebody because they don't want to
admit the fact that he's his sexual
deviancy is an addiction is a real issue
but people go yes on the tough but if he
goes dude I was on heroin I was [ __ ]
and I went and got help and I'm trying
to clean my people would have been like
dude his heart with mental illness
though to say yes same thing people
people choose what they want to give you
a pass for sex has always been something
that's unforgivable like sexual
transgressions are somehow they destroy
you
yeah when Terry Crews came out I was
like I was a sex addict and I remember
most guys like what the [ __ ] Katie was
like I was addicted to porno I would
jack off every day I'm like ah where's
this group that was where you guys mean
that we meet at the Grove every no but
that's my thing is like again it's like
that we give such there's such resonance
to addiction in our society but people
choose which addictions yeah oh by the
way there's also a lot of I'm reading
this book Kandi's really gives off your
this book yeah it's a very good book yes
trout Straus wrote the book the truth
he got caught cheating on his girlfriend
and went to sex rehab and went to sex
addiction and then then went looked at
every expert on this stuff and it was
fascinating to see when you what they're
doing now with so men there's this
evolutionary biologist who studied this
more than anybody else and she basically
came out and said she's a woman she goes
you know what it's a basically yeah I'm
real sorry how to girls really and
basically he said she said human beings
especially men are essentially
adulterous creatures and she does all
this study and history and everything
else
cheater by nature but what what the sex
addiction business and it's a business
is this you you are men men a lot of men
either watch porn stray lust other women
think about other women and there is a
an industry that will that will tell you
essentially that you have a sex
addiction and that you actually
pornography women in general and break
them in the body parts and they create a
pathology around just how your mind is
yeah and then and then there's real
money in treating you which then becomes
a major business because they can bill
your what's the truth so what was this
true so it's a really really interesting
book and that guys like to [ __ ] other
girls basically about about whether or
not monogamy is natural is possible
without giving up other things it's a
fascinating book I recommend it highly
absolutely
is there any conclusion I'm halfway
through does he give any sort of insight
like very much so the inside is the and
he really stirs feel your gain he really
earnest he earnest went and was ride to
really solve this problem he's very
charismatic conceive know what it sounds
like it sounds like a very successful
I'm sorry to his girlfriend Ono he also
know to make us millions of my bad I'm
gonna ring they're not dating anymore
it's [ __ ] Bruno I know I'm teasing
rudely on he wrote a book with David
Nabarro to he's a very well yeah he's a
he was that he was a he was a journalist
for journalists for Rolling Stone
magazine and when he wrote the game had
changed everything it was a fad that's a
fascinating book to he went into dating
about picking girls no one studied all
men here okay the truth come on after
that nice can I take something about to
him wrote a book about ping girls up and
then wrote a book about you wrote a book
about he went and studied the people
that teach men how to pick up women
precisely and he studied the guys that
are masters and when I first moved to
Los Angeles my first place that I lived
I lived with two dudes one of the dudes
was a extremely socially awkward
probably on the spectrum sweet dude out
there space cadet
he read that [ __ ] book I am not
kidding transformed
is what I swear to god truck with my own
eyes he saw I was a guy times you start
to get girls do you blue do my mind I
read that Clement came to our apartment
I was like this guy doesn't [ __ ] it's
true this guy can't be Fox no oh he
[ __ ] it blue we start dressing
different impressing different later boy
I think there's no say it's dangerous
it's dangerous information I read it and
I went oh I'm not gonna I'm not using
any of these techniques because they
would work it's what I watched a man so
much kid who admittedly I hope he hears
he'll be doesn't hear that he well he
used to when he was in his in in college
he was so like me he was so much of a
recluse yeah that he would piss in
Gatorade bottles in there in the
basement of the apartment he lived in
because he didn't feel like going out up
to the ladies know I've been no no no
he's not it's more like he was just kind
of like so inside scared anxiety Wow
yeah this guy flipped the [ __ ] coin
and then here he is he's got girls
coming over to my apartment he's
lighting candles this guy he's getting
girls down yeah I got a couple of girls
coming over
oh my I was like who's this [ __ ] guys
to piss in bottles
you used to bottle piss I said then I go
why did you write the game he goes I was
lonely
that was low man I didn't like being
lonely and I never had a date in high
school or college and now well I mean it
the [ __ ] works
what does that mean what is this even
that's the trails before and after
before he wrote the book in the nasty
road and that's not him he's an
intellectual who does these experiments
so he plays characters yeah he does
these experiments he's a journalist who
him meshes himself in the world and
actually goes through it and it's
[ __ ] that looks like Elon Musk before
and after
yeah really I never seen you on before
hit the lottery I saw like an old video
and he's like a dude Elon Musk is one of
those guys Elon Musk you get him on the
podcast right now go up go up the third
picture with PayPal look at that's Elon
on the right no yeah what happened bro
money the top right number the top right
[Music]
Gillian's bro Oh Heath look good his
hair looks good he dresses good I love
it
he looks like he's in a movie right
there I'm in a movie what movie you
shooting Ilan you sexy [ __ ] ease in a
courtroom winning money it's believed
that PayPal pictures there's a nerd go
to that Tesla jacket less ponder second
a Tony Hawk Christmas second picture
visca yeah look at that Tessa look at my
[ __ ] jackets my company she looks
cool we gonna ask me some questions I'm
in my warehouse of the company that I
own my wife has a real thing for him all
those do you know how many women I know
that say that that's the guy is that my
wife is on abash Woodley in love go down
can we scroll down to some other photos
and see what else we got
he might get him on the phone they're
going that to it they were going that
that yeah
hello he was dating a rich old girl
Amber Heard and then they broke up right
something happened something bad
happened right did something bad happen
did you I couldn't get out the door cuz
all the money I was just kicking up bad
she was sick you dated this girl she was
dating her now
oh wow that's uzt a mortician what's her
name I forgot oh nice is she famous she
is now cuz he's like here's the bill yes
I wonder if he does like the Jeter thing
you know when Jeter like foxing gives
you like a gift bag with a baseball in
it I wonder if he gives you like a test
so if he's like get the [ __ ] out of here
kid hula and here's a USB but what if
you saw the girl that used to [ __ ] get
the but get the best I said like the PD
100 and then you got the three the new
no the $50,000 one no that'd be sad he's
like yes you gotta go
I saw him there with crimes in da van at
oh did you go down a little bit let's
keep going I'll look at him as a kid I'm
gonna be a rich kid nah cute they're
cute kids Andrew come on yeah look I
mean you know I mean no you're a
good-looking guy I was a cute you've
always gotten good try to do Andrew
Santino kids see if it does I don't
think those young Andrew grow up playing
baseball in Chicago they look like the
kiddies play some baseball
you're an as a wooden baseball
basketball I still play but you know
what and you still play what nah see go
to play in college d1 none of that none
of that I'll go you own that Perry Poe
let's not use it we're not a name II
know you've read here bro yes how good
were you at baseball Andrew basketball
was my best sport by a landslide really
now see if you go on my Instagram I got
pictures of me when I was a little baby
we're family yup brothers sisters just
one sister
I wasn't it I was an athlete still an
athlete they'll break it is I'm still in
a challenging yeah well I'm still an
athlete all right take it easy all right
I'll school you on the QQ scrolling down
let's go through my grandma real quick
there's me with Ron Jeremy the pipe King
keep going oh wow is the hedgehog a porn
keep going through where are you doing a
little Dicky where do we did a pilot
yeah we do with the mustache over there
he's like really a dude right there
right there that that's a poster for gay
men to do does like that think I was
shown as Bush we saw earlier if you're
in a gay farmers if you're if you're in
a redheaded gay farmers that guy with
the mustache pick an apple and [ __ ]
you're right right man if you like to
pick apples and get banged by a random I
like carrot you want me to dump in your
mouth hey keep going down little Dickey
good dude I mean look at me as a kid on
the lake and like Michigan yeah there
get out of my face with attitude kid I
got my lookit I got my Lacoste shirt on
you look 40 super [ __ ] that looks maybe
there's another one I'm not sold on this
kid yeah that's gotta be boy there's
more for serious keep going that's me
naked show Bryan the monoamine ABC let
me take in the [ __ ] by the way I'm not
mad at the body well done sir weeks way
I had to jerk off on show time
we did a nude scene right jerk I'm
jerking off and I get a phone call that
my dad is dead let's go down look at
that basketball camp Duke and UNC there
you go getting cuter on the Left than
when you got braces got that software
time I went through it Oz mrs. Runkle
City you've got me down struggle city is
good hold on keep going you're doing
that around like a [ __ ] good teacher
I rented a Ferrari for the Showtime
promo we did I rented the ninth I rented
that 95 I wanted the one that Jordan was
in love it keep going down Q oh that's
me wait oh that's me 45 go up in the red
look at the red shirt I said I'm Jerry
Mix Seinfeld look at me big jeans bro
well the big jeans are oh what's the
deal with big jeans those are like that
I can hear my glasses I can hear my dad
go tuck it in tuck it in but I don't
like talk it in keep going down there's
got to be one more real cute when I'm
kid kid I'm still waiting for like a
real q1 my profile is of me as a kid but
I can't but yeah look at that go up look
at what my little sister okay all right
there we go
there we go oh one eye on the cyst she's
taking a [ __ ] yeah that's that's
powerful
that's definitely my mom my mom my mom
hat is very very funny but secret funny
those eyes belong in American Horror
Story yeah go up real quick there's a
picture or go cuz I see into the hall
down let me see if it's maybe down
there's a picture this is how funny my
mother okay look this one me petting a
horse look at that look at go pet the
horse look at this is how funny my mom
it [ __ ] [ __ ] it just [ __ ] that's what my
mom would do yeah
so I'll get a picture with the poop with
the tour such a [ __ ] my mom was very
funny was she is funny okay
she's lost her sense of humor she's lost
of the humor since since Joe Biden died
since Joe Biden passed out of that can I
have his crown get out of this Graham
Graham Doug get out all that like do you
have a blurry picture of Adam ray that's
a video if we do this bit a bit where we
chase each other let me say you got
angry yeah what'd you get a nice try
sounds like a series we were doing me
talking [ __ ] and then keep going there's
a gate didn't you keep going you going
that keep going way down forgot there's
a J no no I like I get I never get tired
of dumb dumb [ __ ] sock it to me was
like we would we used to do it all the
time of him we run into each other and
then I go home and I did a bit for a
little while Andrew it look at me good
thanks Brian's Brian he's not the
business yeah you left a business when
you okay yeah when they gave you this
offer to do the TV show school do you
think that they do you think then you
think they took a shot on you because
you've been around for too long Andrew
do you think it's shitty questions do
you think it's hey you're being shitty
right please
I mean are you talented undeniably I
will say that I've seen you're very
funny onstage you do great stuff on
camera are you can you hold a show come
on I mean what a bad bet it's ABC that
sings so many ships over there to see
she was gonna [ __ ] fall to the bottom
here sir
I have a number two this fall Bryan
Callen barely makes you laugh what's the
promo gotta say I'm with Tim Meadows for
[ __ ] sake oh man well he's not gonna
be able to pull you up from anything
he's ways funnier than you he's gonna be
way up top making everyone laugh and
they're gonna go who's this guy dragging
down Meadows Tim Meadows SNL night
dragon lady's man ladies man one of the
greatest most brilliant comedians of all
times and they got you they got me
they've got me but I'm gonna learn from
him and I'm gonna pull it up and we're
gonna get you on there is it gay I would
love to let me be honest I'm so happy
for you Jenny when I heard that new you
know who told me D'Elia crystally a few
guys don't know who yes he does he's
like a podcast he's a podcast guy
youtuber yeah yeah and he he said did
you hear about Kalin and my initial
thought this is your Saudi dime
no no not death he's young and he's in
[ __ ] he said did you hear about about
Kalin and I said I knew it because the
first time I met Kalin nice always nice
but like a femine of eminent and I
thought he is gay I know and I thought
this was a come out party and I got
excited I said we're gonna have a come
out party for about time it's about Jack
it's about time he's been to Brendan put
him up to this did you shut that hashtag
it's about time there's a whole thing of
r.i.p Kalin as I died no it's people
were sending yeah I never I never but
I'm reading in my life
well we know yeah you thought Chris
Brown didn't beat your Jana five years
ago I know you don't news all blues yeah
I know I know I was genuinely happy when
Chris told me about it cuz I thought
that's that is a wonderful what a
wonderful thing it's hard for people in
our business that are talented to get
stuff let's be honest a lot of people
get stuff and you're like I cannot
believe this is happening
mm-hmm I'm not gonna get mad I don't get
mad at anymore I just can't believe
they're not finding the best people for
things sometimes where you go how is
that the best shot how did you guys not
I don't know so business
I'm happy for you thanks pal and if if
if if if if I feel like it I will do I
will do a couple episode I will get the
offer no I don't know and it'll say
it'll be seems with Brian and I'll go
can I be with Tim no you gave me a
comment now you're being shitty shitty I
don't want to work with you I'd rather
work with Tim now I have some surprises
up my sleeve I've got some committees
surprises up my sleeve
not right now you don't already stuff is
sounding good at all for us a bad pitch
me on why I should work shoes with you I
don't want those what he told me if
they're Game of Thrones I don't I don't
want that stuff Game of Thrones no but
that's cursed we talked about em I
didn't have any interest okay I didn't
either
for a year and I just got up on season
seven like six months so that just set
me back what you just said makes me turn
off more am I gonna get daunting I'll
give you there and in an hour of how
many episodes bad enough by 10 enough so
7490 hours Brandon what do you think
waste your time is that true yes no I'm
kidding let me put it you like this it
is amazing he hasn't seen The Sopranos
ever he's gotta get involved in this
right I did that I don't know you know I
don't have any room for that that kind
of stuff is embarrassing
thank you wrong you need to watch are
you trying to say the game of thrones he
is even near soprano one of the greatest
written television shows you ever seen a
white Walton
let me tell you something dragon I don't
I don't [ __ ] with dragon sizes you
[ __ ] do I didn't hang on sister
[ __ ] all over that show yeah they do
incest and Dragons I don't like either
of them how about that I don't either
no The Sopranos never seen Sopranos you
got bears is that best seasons but you
gotta get under your belly C's not
enough oh I know it's not enough
no no there was six snow yeah it was
what's at six or seven it was six six
it's the best show it's the best you
know I heard the ending it just goes
black and everyone's so mad well not you
[ __ ] yourself
we don't understand you don't understand
you don't understand now I need you to
watch The Sopranos that's about a guy
named mafia hey one of the greatest
actors that's ever lived one of the
great shot leaves one of the best roles
and the best shows wrecked
you'll love it be you know you passed
away Brown yeah you'll love him he died
he died with Joe Biden [ __ ] loved it
you know you will love it that you seen
ozark oh okay so when someone says why
don't you watch Game of Thrones I'm
watching Ozark I don't want you watch
one scene of I suppress throw that up
there can be longer fellas I gotta leave
in five minutes
are you all right we'll just carry on
your brother all right what time is it
101 200 is Joey Diaz and I know it looks
like how does Joe Diaz not get cast in
this [ __ ] show now not watching Joey
I always loved to shirts Sonia the best
shirts what do you say I'd like this big
Tommy Bahama shirt so you got to be fat
to wear those off yeah you do only do
that on snow you love this show will not
talking about you know down the dock
driving off some of that Japanese
technology hash knows a guy no yeah so
what else is going on nothing
[Music]
come on the gun charge Dean that's
supposed to sell me a gun charge bounced
and we're gonna knock off some Japanese
tech what else you got let me massage my
feet more let me shine my shoes
that's hilarious what is he doing you
guys do Jamie starts massaging him
selfie give me a better soon I gotta go
back to this show shows that good
podcast watches issue the wire yeah I
love the wire phenomena you saw seasons
though I don't see never love is love
say it's the greatest series of all time
mm it's up there oh but there's nothing
like this Tom mine again mine the [ __ ]
the matter with you how much has we got
that iroc-z Jersey so Jersey so
aggressive speeding in the neighborhood
come on where is this on TV anymore now
this is one of the greatest shows ever
it really it's not oh you guys said that
several times
Tony oh it was that one like every award
be your time alright now I'm gonna get
sucked in I'm me too
I started getting sucked in and get some
we get so deep I'm gonna go home and I'm
gonna have to watch I want to get deep
into a bed I need a new series you gotta
watch my watch to see all the students
are on HBO - I'm sure demand yeah yeah
I'm sure I think we're Netflix by now
gotta be on they got oh no I doubt
Netflix did the Netflix buy that from
HBO they'd be I doubt it
what didn't they [ __ ] buy no no it's
on each Amazon Amazon sure I don't have
did you do it special did you shoot a
special I did whose afforded I did with
comedy dynamics now where I'm editing it
today I'm going there you want to go to
Netflix I do yeah you think the n-word
that's the real n-word yeah I talked
about on Rogen saying I I don't I don't
get it I don't know if they want me over
there at all I don't really know any
banks me over there well I don't know I
don't know any better
I just don't think like I don't get it
but like Netflix is like Netflix is like
Woody Allen where you're like where
Woody Pitts will people like Woody Allen
son of a [ __ ] yeah it's like he offered
you a role it's like mmm what day do we
start here hangout like Netflix I'm like
you why are you saying that I'm offering
because I'm because because I mean in
the sense of my dude did you did you try
to sell your last question to them they
know no Showtime hit and gave me a deal
so I did a special show that was the
only thing I've ever done I did a
half-hour comedy central and then
Showtime was like do you want to do a
special was great it was fun it was it
was it was okay I just like I just I
wanted more eyes on it and Netflix was
the place and like after I did that I
was like I really want to do some with
them and I think we've reached out to
them and they were like yeah you know we
just for hours they're looking for
theater acts I can't sell theaters yet
and then they were like well what about
the half's or whatever and then we just
have them kind of packed up right now
and so I just think maybe it's a don't
really like you that my don't really
like your [ __ ] that much which is fine
it's a lot of stuff and I'm going on
it's a million things right it's a
million things but the truth is I I say
that analogy not that Netflix is
touching their stepdaughters I just mean
like everyone is mad at them a little
bit right now because it's like god it's
[ __ ] making a million specials and
everyone is and what the [ __ ] it's kind
of clogged it's doing this thing to the
comedy world but any comical complains
about it if they picked up the phone and
we're like hey we'll give you special
Mario
[ __ ] everyone go I can't wait it can
change everything you rhythm it can
change they could also tell you hey we
will buy your special we're also gonna
bury it and you'd go dug fine doesn't
matter because it lives there forever
yep and you know who has Netflix the
[ __ ] world everybody this is the one
thing I say about Comedy Central I've
done business with them for years I love
those guys they were the first people to
put me on TV
Canada can't see Comedy Central yep what
do you need to know North America can't
even see [ __ ] you put on no Netflix is
[ __ ] everywhere everyone else needs
to just catch up and go where everywhere
we're for go here have all of it any
good on-demand digital stuff like that
too you should pay one fee like Netflix
and you get all the [ __ ] you need how
many central goes give me ten bucks a
year you can [ __ ] have everything
we've ever made
yeah call me central online make their
own the Showtime movie you know when you
guys no no because short time is a very
limited market it's only for user basis
yeah if you're not a short time user you
can't see it if not a Netflix user you
ask someone for the password now you see
it it's like hey does your cousin have a
pet yeah sure everyone has Netflix it's
like short time was hard it was they
treated me well I like those people and
goes that Showtime special I shot at two
years ago it came out a year and a half
of them yeah the other thing guys are
doing too is if you do a special on
Showtime or HBO what some of the bigger
names are doing is it gets released on
there and that's a certain time you can
release it digitally we have that
contract too yeah they really they did
the same to Sebastian I think did the
same thing with Showtime blocked off his
early ones I think he he bought back
from them or I mean he got the contract
released from them and then he's like
yeah but there's a guy that popped off
with just Showtime so there's something
to be said about talent it's also before
Netflix came along you know right but at
the same time it was also just cuz he's
oh so he's amazing and the stars were
right for Hulu Amazon sometimes talent
wins just awesome he was good he could
have done on YouTube read it wouldn't
matter would have done it on reddit do
you know read it is bright yeah I read
it all the time and that's not a real
it's not a reading thought huh it's not
a reading I only read things you only
write I read special you guys got it
from here got it from here buddy never
take it where you headed
what's the meeting for what the hell no
we know see you buddy have a go get out
of here you sis I'm gonna
[ __ ] cute boy your peanuts no there you
go same lips so sad ya know why go sit
in this chair now wanna yeah come on
over here buddy
kid over here you know what I like about
you whoa I should do this more than
Brendan this is really comfortable for
me you're good and you got some length
of bone how tall are you 6-1 6-2 on a 62
on your you're a legit 6 1 yeah I'm
probably closer to 6 - but 6-1 6-2 and
you've got long legs and long arms yeah
yeah yeah why you can play basketball
that's what he you have you ever don't
yep
is that true I don't a lot is that true
yeah I have a lot of proof of it too
that's my I took a bunch of pictures
when I was in college because I knew
that years later I would stop being able
to and I think I got to show people that
I can do it that's because my kids gonna
go you couldn't [ __ ] don't you can
palm a ball mm-hmm yeah certain balls
are easier yeah leather balls are harder
composite leather is the easiest real
and the NBA ball hard bottle palm it's
just guys just not yeah composite
leather I can do this guy's I've always
wanted to be all I wanted was to be able
to have the kind of physical structure
that could dunk a basketball that would
be pretty cool jump jumping was always
my I want just two inches longer towards
if I had two inches more yeah well cuz I
can jump okay I just need like two more
inches but now there's like there's you
go on YouTube there's like drills where
people teach themselves how to jump
there's guys that have like small
verticals yeah they train and they get
bigger verticals yeah - am I too busy
for that for me it's like learning how
to do a backflip I'd like to do that and
I could I don't I'm too busy you don't
need to do a backflip though there's not
one time your life when someone says do
a backflip and we won't write I just
Kelly I want to have some era where I
call it air air awareness I want to be
an aerial I want to be an aerial athlete
I mean aerialist
I want to be an aerialist you want to be
up in the air doing stuff sometimes in
case I gotta you could go pro at any
sport would it have been well would it
if our core not a pro sport
now if I can go pro if I made my
druthers yeah the sport I love yes
tennis boxing boxing boxing tennis just
seems such a bore I would love to
I really love boxing so I think if I
come to it at a young age two things
would happen one I would have become
obsessed and given myself brain damage
trying to become good or the other is I
would have gotten hit hard enough so I
stopped
so usually put you out well you can you
can you can box it's really fun and then
you can take a shot and I've been
knocked out how's your chin it's I have
no idea not good
I've been knocked out plenty when I say
plenty I probably knocked out I knocked
out five times when I was in Taekwondo
you definitely got brain damage yeah
when I was when I was when I was when I
detected you get caught with the wheel
kicking caught with a roundhouse
whatever was you'd have a cold one aid
spar you wouldn't be thinking and you
turn somebody kick in the face whatever
they would just happen never had it
happen in a tournament but boxing and
and I came back out you would always be
a little shite I was being a little
gun-shy when you spar it would ruin you
for six months sometimes six months yeah
because when you get hit in the head for
me for me I hated it some guys get hit
in the head in there like they come back
more me I wanted to cry literally would
want to cry and I would not be alright I
just not be alright because I'd be so
vulnerable and for six months I'd be
gun-shy and my sparring would suck
boxing I've not gotten there because I
spar guys who are not good
I spar guys who are and we're moving
around and it's it's it's moving around
what's the age and weight are they your
everybody's younger than me everybody's
younger everybody whoop your ass no
people don't whup your ass
no but but about in a street fight do
you think you'd be good in a street
fight I don't know
see if had some fighting yeah I think
about that you're probably better at me
at boxing but I think I'm like but I was
a wrestler but I think I might murder
you want a street fight well I was a
wrestler but I just all up I'm staying
up all have you ever had any have you
ever have you ever done any stand-up
comedy fighting I've been doing it for a
while if you haven't black bone
Taekwondo and I'm box a lot I know but I
just want to fight you in the street
yeah I'll kill you okay
and I don't like the way you're looking
at me right now cuz I'm gonna do it your
hand now you got some long hands but I'm
gonna get under your [ __ ] whatever
you throw I'm gonna dip and I'm gonna be
close to you on either side and then I'm
gonna work your goddamn body okay you
know what though I just hug we're gonna
we're gonna loop this clip at the
hospital to the doctor that he fights
are a whole different gaming all I
learned was street fighting as a kid
that's all I knew yeah you seem like a
you have some we were a comic and you
have your athletic so you have some
anger I just got made fun of when I was
a kid so I would just punch people these
are true stories I got kicked out of
kindergarten for fighting you get your
Italian you're from Chicago
[ __ ] yeah anger you'll fight oh man I
was so quick Oh shoes you of all the
comments there a lot of Congress you
know if I had to go fight if I was in a
bar and they said I mean really one of
the first guys I'm gonna call who's the
last guy you would call Bobby Lee yeah
but I bet if he shows his dick they
clear out nobody go on but but I love
Bobby but they're most comics are not
gonna get your back and they're also not
gonna be able to fight Bobby's the
reason that I'm at the Comedy Store
yeah but then again you know all this
stuff comes from my insecurity and
self-loathing with my neighbor goes man
you're so disciplined you work out I go
I'm not disciplined
I'm just insecure and I don't like
myself said you're secure enough to have
a belly yeah I am not secure enough at
51 I still have to go spar in case
something happens yeah that's who you're
dealing with yeah I say I stay in shape
I stay in shape because I can't be I
can't be sad and fat that's right I can
be sad and in shape yeah I don't get sad
by the way I definitely get say I'm
lucky that way I have your shirt on - I
said I'm dum-dum I'm a dumb I don't
think deeply I can take a nap and I'm
fine no matter what happens I can never
take a nap Jack if I take a nap I'm
reeling if I'm sleeping if I'm sleeping
well mm-hmm and I'm working out very
little gets me down what's your butcher
what is your workout routine are you
every day so I I do a combination of
CrossFit and I box a lot now especially
now I'm I don't like CrossFit
I don't either and my heart races every
time I have to go train with my buddy
Nick who I train now a deuce which is an
open garage on Lincoln and everyone can
see you everybody stronger than me
everybody's tougher than me everybody's
a real crossfitter and then there's the
[ __ ] the actor the sweetie who wears
a hat so the Sun doesn't hit his face I
wear one of those long one of those golf
hats the golf look at huh
yeah I'm not what do you weigh I'm 170
hops 165 if you're like lean yeah I'm
lean right now because I because of my
psoriasis I have to eat very very
specifically what listen what's the
rises again this on your skin yeah it
hurts so much but I've seen this on the
commercial cheese it's so much better
look at how much better my legs there
but Dad that's where it is I see this on
commercials and then they have to cover
it up because they're embarrassed oh
yeah did I get I mean I get plaque
psoriasis and I'm not careful what is
that from this side my size my body is
that from sin autoimmune diseases good
stuff no cure he's just from like a
cream it won't work the way you were
growing the way you grow now they don't
know I add your parents have it no it
just happened 12 years ago but it
started getting really bad in the past
year do you think it has something to do
with you the way you live your life oh
well you mean because I'm a high stress
never relaxed person you were talking
about Capri and my I mean you're right
you must take time in life you have to
and I I propose this you won't do it but
I believe that once a month once every
two weeks we should be having dinners
with smart fun people yes just let's
make I'll hire they gotta come cook
let's sit around have a meal and eat
some goddamn food you're more than what
you and if you invite me I'll go not yet
Kat you're too young you're a gal can I
can I tell you something yeah I'm gonna
take you to dinner because of what he
just Jesus no I like Kat I don't know
Kat yet oh I don't know we're either but
I just invited her to dinner because dad
dudes my brother right there Chin's
coming he's definitely not your brother
literally not blood there's no later
we're related by how there's a deep
thing we have the same mom mom so you
have the same mother
we do what is her name Janice Jennifer
Jennifer Michelle it's a hyphenated name
- Jennifer Michelle Michelle yes we're
and where were you born
South Korea Seoul Korea and where was he
born Sumner yeah you were born in South
Korea in that area yeah what's the what
is it would like where what specifically
daddy's sorry
so where he was talking about so same
spot in the same yeah pretty much the
same in the same hospital Wow what's the
age difference right now yeah that this
said right now the age difference is
exactly 11 years yeah 11 years
yeah he's your little brother yeah okay
can I tell you something yeah
it all adds up I believe every piece of
it
every set everything adds up I'm makin
cats to dinner because of what you just
said yeah I also want to come too you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna take
her to lunch and then come to your
dinner with the fun thing and I might
bring her you gonna crash the dinner
with her she'll be mine she's on your
arm
it's nan to a married yeah yeah but on
my arm I don't I don't own her Agnes
[ __ ] are you pregnant no but she will be
with your redheaded baby and and you'll
be beating her what do you do set it
yeah that I did say it
what kind of we would have a very
odd-looking baby oh you're both
good-looking people
yeah but not half asian half a red that
could be tough he's not Scottish our
society the most beautiful baby I love
this attitude I love this attitude yeah
but but but you're talking about a kind
of white I'm a unique species of why you
guys got to be careful because you might
just fall in love what do you think I'm
doing over him because he looks like a
he looks like a very Anglo white if
someone says yeah yeah if someone said
half Sicilian 100% oh but you look white
yeah you have a white man if says who
what's a white man they'd probably draw
you yeah I had a director say that
because I never recognize you I go I
goes you just look like every man you
look like I'm Eric Gerets leader my
buddy Alice but thanks Carol this this
is a nice point isn't it nice to to look
like just I got a guy's guy a guy
there's not like look guys guys in the
business I got shoulders for days my
waist is so tapered I got a dick on me
and so there's a lot of stuff going on
ice big killer shoulders humble - I'm
humble I got a nice dick I got in
killers shoulders and I got a lot of
fast twitch muscle which is why I can
almost dunk a basketball home I had two
more inches of [ __ ] bone if there's
one thing that you need in your life
that you could change what would it be
I'd like to be less impulsive I'd like
to be good luck yeah I'd like to be less
neurotic I guess I just do think you
would literally yeah you really can't
change him no and I don't know if I
could I want if somebody of the day I am
Who I am I'm a flawed guy Barry flawed
yeah very very very very flaw oh my god
oh my god oh my there's a blog called
flawed flawed
very flawed Callum calm I contribute
what I think about this though what if
someone came up to you I had this like
daydream in the shower sometimes a guy
from Dubai
I don't know wise to buy because I like
to buy and he's like I'll give you five
hundred million dollars to quit the
business disappear forever would you do
it first of all I didn't know he was
from Dubai but of Spanish or would you
hear it that's very good for five
hundred million five hundred dollars you
kill you quit you quit would you quit
the business for a half million dollars
and disappear it's a very good question
and the answer might be yes and here's
why hmm
I would I since I've done it yeah I feel
it
you've already been in the business yeah
for 32 years dedicate myself to
something completely different and it
might be something as simple as golf
literature and just writing oh I think
man Golf is a golf literature it's just
all about golf because literature just
all about stories about golf I wear a
stations fiction no goth Bagger Vance
you'd read a bag of answer I'd write a
Bagger Vance story over and over again
that's cute
thank you yeah I don't know I've hundred
I think I might leave the business do it
every day in the shower I think would
you I have a daydream every day every
single before I came to this [ __ ]
thing are you at a daydream in the
morning of a man coming up to me on the
street grabbing me throwing me in a van
and going 500 million why is that
because I want to get home to [ __ ] out
of this business
yeah I hate it so my [ __ ] hate it I
really appreciate all saying is a
nightmare why do people think it's fun
it's such a hustle dude it sucks
it's dog sad people don't realize what a
[ __ ] hustle it is and it's up to me
every single day to figure out a way to
make money
hence neuroses hence tenseness hence
psoriasis yeah seriously you know where
this guy my mother said that to me my
brother goes yeah I have so much
pressure on my shoulders like a poopa
Dimond today I could [ __ ] out a diamond
this afternoon I'm in the middle of my
cup in the middle of buying a house Oh
God put a gun on my [ __ ] I don't shoot
my penis right off my body his houses
are so cheap in lausanne they're cheap
and they're easy to buy and they give
out loans I just throw them at ya they
don't look like every [ __ ] detail I I
know all about that they had I to take
pictures of my shoes they had one they
want to know what kind of shoes I had
it's the most disgusting
you're almost you know you're joking but
it's it is a big piece that invasive
it's invasive it's almost that of video
now tell us your they wanted to know
well they make sure that money is not
laundered that's the home stolen they
wanted most in to make sure what
happened but god I wish
in 2006 when they were giving away
[ __ ] houses you know if you just had
eyes to eyeballs yeah if you were awake
they give you a house my gardener got
along for real
but is it foreclosed on now or hey my
gardener about $500,000 a year half a
million your son well first of all my
grounds go on for you know as far as you
can see and what do you gotta do
something with this you've got a nine or
ten acres out there don't yet I do
Jesus Hollywood in the dead center of
Hollywood get 10 acres of land with you
won't see it because the wall is so
[ __ ] high so we bought we just bought
a half bed half bath it's 16 square feet
that's really small right-hand-rule know
what do mean that size no I mean I don't
mean to be in self well it just seems
now let's have a [ __ ] new show let's
have a bedroom have half bed half past
16 square feet there is a we don't call
it a driveway we call it an up way
because it's a few chunks of concrete I
go near the front two or three million
dollars it's two and a half yeah it's
two and a half no you can't look at a
place if you come in if you come in to
buy a house in Los Angeles I'm sorry to
everybody out there this is the truth
yeah if you go if you want to buy a
house and you have 1 million dollars
which is a shitload not a million nobody
has a million but if you can a finance
if you finance a million American dollar
financing so you can put two hundred
grand down they will let you when you
look at the houses available for a
million dollars you'll you're not
getting a yard you're not getting
anything you don't get it they'll laugh
at you yeah
don't let the ruh-roh cur will be like
the roof is separate you have to pay for
the room out something else up it's that
[ __ ] up I've never I've never felt so
disgusted when I when I started looking
for a house failure yeah
loser sometimes we would go to like
eight million dollar houses just for
just for fun so fun and I like toying
with them I go I like I like poking I
like looking at imperfections an eight
million dollar ten million dollar houses
and going I don't know why these windows
are set this well my brother-in-law it
made a lot of money retired at 40 and I
went for the work in the day yeah I love
him back smartest guy I know
smarts kind of what he do - what'd he do
high finance and he's the smartest man
in the world and I and I went and I he's
so smart that David Blaine was looking
for the smartest guy in the world David
Glenn had 12 questions
he has Bill Gates everybody I don't
think it made his show I asked my
brother-in-law all the questions there
are logic questions my brother got all
of them but one doesn't matter the point
is he's that smart and retired of 40 I
went to look at the houses he was
looking at I went with him where where
was [ __ ] here in LA yeah it's a then
he ended up buying a he bought a very
beautiful beautiful what part of the
city to look alike it's one of the big
house beautiful Toluca Lake up there
come on gorgeous start a family he got a
family got four kids four perfect dad
perfect dad he's a better person in life
men are men and girl boys and girls kids
and in women there he's he adopted men
from a home now he has a bunch of men
that just live in his home yes that's a
dangerous life so it is they're all
they've all had checkered past what can
I tell you something why you got to
start again somewhere and he's the same
she's the second chance Thomas Louie
call his brother Louie did you look up
did you look up when you fir when you
moved into the area you moved into did
you look up at there's pee toes in the
area and amber yes I did and it looks
like Megan's life it looks like Gamow
you know those textbooks where they show
you people who had measles yeah yeah how
many that's how more to Megan's Law and
look at a map of LA that's how many
people that's already sex there isn't
and there is in the neighborhood without
an offender within there everywhere a
quarter of a mile there everywhere it's
a fact go to Megan's Law website look at
the map so of course I look up I look up
in the area yeah you're thinking about
having kids I just I just just in
general yeah I look up in the area yeah
Oh speckled
pervs everywhere it looks like somebody
it's like that somebody it's like a
measles Megan's Law map yes sir just
should go go click on the website they
gotta have a map link on there right you
don't see it here type in Meg Islam map
oh no you're not a robot mm-hmm you're
her Ron Funches has a joke about that no
he's like pretty precarious a robot
asking me if I'm not a robot this a
genius I was like that's a genius joke
I'm not supposed to do somebody else's
jokes right that's a Brogan says that
all that zero zero six six that's what
we're at right now
Oh where's it gonna be tougher because
it's go down to LA go zoom is get all
the way down to LA go to nine zero zero
two eight nine zero zero two eight let's
see what they say
C humph let's see many pervs there are
over there I don't know that's
residential area there's a couple no
Julie I can't be right I mean they're
areas it's just like there you go yeah
closer you get the more cats yep look at
that Wow where can you go that they're
not there good luck
click on one of the dots it'll tell you
what they did - it'll show you a photo
and what they did look at a woman that's
a woman forget that oh man what did it
say for her I'm not worried about the
women go to the men she probably just
hanging out - male that's a male that's
a man yeah a Dan Ramirez gonna go nuts
that's a guy they just changed oh yeah
male well a male Hispanic lewd or
lascivious acts with the child 14 years
ago come on
yeah Wow is that [ __ ] crazy they're
everywhere
see this guy Robert Graham King raped by
force of Raider by force of fear Jesus
Christ try getting a job good luck with
that
Oh chef Shannon Bala what is hers
possessive control obscene matter
depicting minor in sexual conduct so
child porn apt yeah by the way why don't
these people that look at child porn why
do they keep it I never understood that
they all find them with it like they
keep it they have it all over the place
they have flags and stuff on the website
you can find these people are they trade
these things make them catch them you
ever get to see I get scared sometimes
I'm looking at porn oh that like what if
like a video I click on that's on my
normal porn site puts me in a category
in I'm like we're not well that sucks me
up that scares that happen does that
happen I don't know yes yes it does
all right get rid of these do some
current events
yeah sounds good give it to me all right
Hornish yeah this thing was going around
on barstool sports bar stroll bar stool
outdoors so it's this animal that's an
okapi isn't it or is that a baby rhino
it looks like it's something call it's
up here oh it's in me here yeah so
Jaguars eat those I think so it has this
jail
people were saying they're saying like
is it a dick or is it his tail that's
his dick oh no it's his tail you see it
tuck that's its [ __ ] so you think it's a
no that's his tail that's a stick is it
a stick so we were tagging this a lot
firing kid and you guys but I looked
into it and it is its dick yeah it has
the biggest largest dick and total body
out of the entire animal
kingdom that looks like a man's arm you
look like somebody holding a pig that's
it look at the horns what's its name at
up here I'm gonna be I'm gonna call me
that's a very they're eaten by Andrew
the - Pierce and Jags Ethan or something
they're cute
you could eat their penis for four meals
- look type here penis
tap here penis do you go there to appear
penis I'd like just a lemon pepper crust
on it sear like as lemon pepper see I
need mine well done are you doing yeah
I'm a medium guy when it comes it's
appeared I know some people like it rare
not me oh that's offensive now I gotta
cook it a little bit like it I like it
marinated I like it brined and then I
like it cooked well do you just like
that I like it I like it jerk jerk -
papaer yeah sure if your penis or jerk -
pear [ __ ] cut it into strips mr. salty
and dry in the Sun George Fox you guys
have shred it I put it in a crock pot
one time and it came out so soft yeah
just a little bit of like how do you get
a green sauce always seems so crunchy
well it's it's cook time that's because
I because I that's cuz when I slave it
appear I always get it hard first mmm
and so that might be the problem
why why do you do that um I don't know
it's just been it's my custom it's my
culture mm-hmm interesting yeah you
don't know there's no need to do that
whatsoever
um you just you just got a cut and not
at all sure that's what we do yeah sure
yeah yeah I know I know yeah I get that
yes what's the other event all right so
I'm sure you guys heard about this in
turn that tweeted yeah yeah she said
like for NASA my dick yeah her first
name was everyone shut the F up I got
accepted for a NASA internship and then
this guy Homer Hickam who's part of the
National Space Council he says language
suck my dick and balls I'm working at
NASA he goes and I'm the National Space
I'm on the National Space Council it
oversees NASA fired more she fires so
she was she was like denied the position
but however this guy is actually pretty
cool this Homer Hickam guy because he's
uh he wrote a long letter he wrote a
letter about it he wasn't like making
toner stop the whatever was she saying
he was just kind of saying like you know
just pee do you use less bad language
yeah and it was fine until she told him
to suck her dick and balls yeah let her
saying that she's gonna get a most
likely a better opportunity at NASA like
he didn't want her to get in trouble for
it good friend yes
guy did she get her job back she's gonna
get this right now first of all yeah I
think I'm gonna get my internship again
thank you for all your support but he
says he's gonna get something bigger
better than wishing like this girl is
good is it his point was that's great
and I'm on the council that oversees
NASA
maybe if she doubled down and she goes
still suck my dick again that would have
been cooler she reached out to me with
an unnecessary apology which I hardly
accepted a return of my own after
talking to her I am certain she deserves
a position in the aerospace industry I'm
doing all I can to secure one that will
better she was just excited yeah I think
I work at NASA I think you should be
able to say suck my dick I work at NASA
at NASA you they should all be able to
say that its innovates an imaginary dick
and balls anyway so that's even first of
all you don't know she has never taken a
ball come on bros but it says she what
do you assume mija [ __ ] Schumi Ryan I
can exploit me do you have a ticket uh
balls yes but I don't know that how
would I know that because I even rode it
to you too you have shown your balls
that's why mr. Brian tip here i said i'm
santi no tip here you can't take my [ __ ]
you can't take that [ __ ] yeah is that me
yeah take my joke man you beat me to it
you [ __ ]
suck my dick and balls I work in if they
were smart they'd sell shirts that say
suck my dick and balls I work at Zoo and
I'd buy the [ __ ] out of that so what I'd
buy the [ __ ] out of it they sell it to
us NASA sell it to me NASA stands for
suck my dick know what the right acronym
is and a si I'm so bad with that I don't
know oh my god it's over so uh I don't
know it's the National aerospace
suck ass suck ass yeah all right give me
the next [ __ ] mine this Trump Trump
is warning Google Facebook and Twitter
because he says that they're promoting
fake news whenever you type in his name
oh well you know what
Trump's right every time every time I
read something is like a big sigh
whenever I read these articles out of
him psycho what do you want what am I
supposed to where do I start
I don't get it I don't know what he's
saying what he's saying that the
Internet is out to get him yeah okay
next [ __ ] like it's not at this point
the onion can't even write funnier
articles then whatever is coming up
about him Trump is very sensitive my my
thing is he's just
such a [ __ ] he's such a for such a
tough guy he claims to be such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] he listens to everything
everyone says he's a [ __ ] about
anything you can't even tease the guy
stop being a [ __ ] and it says here that
his economic adviser is gonna look into
it like investigates so if he said on
the way to the bathroom
ignoring the reporter completely we'll
look into it can you [ __ ] off and
whether City regulators and anybody they
better they do that huh could they do
that those Trump had the power to
regulate what Google puts up absolutely
none all right here's why also here's
the beauty of the Internet the Internet
is user based generated right so you
could shut down everything you wanted
more more servers would just pop up and
more user based sites would just
continue to papa the black market of the
Internet would get would become bigger
more publicly dominated yeah right now
these the only things protecting him you
kidding me these are the Twitter is his
best friend
it's his best friend it's his source
it's his promotional tool he couldn't
shut those down if he let the black
market of the Internet become the
dominant Internet he's gonna be way
worse for him yeah because all those
guys that have shitty information on him
it was all out there it's so much easier
for a hack if hackers had their way with
him it would be a different world cuz
you tell me they can't hack into his
[ __ ] I don't know they can hack into
[ __ ] anything you know a lot of a lot
of the hack into the World Bank they
hack in the most secure places we have
on the earth yeah and they just go just
kiddin
yeah they do that to go hey we can a lot
of we can [ __ ] it's a lot of it's like
foreign foreign intelligence agency yes
China Russia China and Russia yeah China
for sure yeah
China is my favorite I want to learn
Chinese recently did you I to give him
all five of my fingerprints and they had
the Luke take a picture and look into my
eyes I think they took a retinal scan
can I tell you something [ __ ] that place
I went to China shook one hand and got
in I don't see none of that what Andrew
I think it's you
why shook a guy's hand he goes welcome
welcome to China
he said that in English because I didn't
none of them spoke Chinese Andrew this
is weird because I was in knowledge gene
I wasn't really I was in Beijing Oh
I went to bashing no none of them spoke
Chinese not one person ah man cuz I said
the guy what head yes said he said she
shot me ha ya and we what we went into
not me because I had to learn I walked
in the guy say welcome to China I said
hey can I get to work and I get working
I got played Chinese beer I had a long
fight it was like an hour-and-a-half
flight from LA to China and right away I
wanted some Chinese food
boom land the Chinese kitchen I think it
was called I don't know I had the best
Chinese dish I've ever had in my life at
a Philly cheesesteak and I had a side of
sauteed spinach yeah that doesn't sound
that's authentic Chinese have you been
to Chinatown here in LA yeah all Philly
cheesesteak spots that that's what
they're known for he'll know about any
of this man are you kidding me no I I
feel like you're lying I had I first of
all had authentic Chinese food Philly
cheesesteaks I just finished and then
Chinese Chinese goodness and authentic
old-school Chinese their oldest sport in
the world yeah I went to go see a rugby
game you could go to China and all I
could find you you could go to China
anywhere I can get on a bicycle and go
was the redhead you could never hide but
you know what's funny though if I rode a
bike around China I would have a bell
cuz I'd want more attention I would the
whole street I wanted a guy with the
bell red head no he was ringing a bell
oh yeah yeah Bell he's right there the
Chinese Bell guy events speaking of
Chinese I don't know if this lady's
Chinese but probably can't tell me about
the story about a woman that grabbed
birds from the street oh yeah so if she
is Chinese well she put down a plastic
bag she picks up pigeons and put them in
plastic bag check it ARDS they're little
birds out there weren't even trained I
saw this she was capturing obviously
eating them by hand she sold it puts in
the bag got great hands I gotta tell you
that's not that's great that's
impressive and it's very gentle she was
good she knows how to do that she was
taught this this is a technique right
this that's that that's her coach right
there that's her bird coach I think it's
great what's what to come i birds we
chickens why can't you steal a bird
officer my grandmother used to they had
chickens oh he used to break their necks
and shoot in front of us yep and then
she'd been she'd feather him and all
that stuff mm-hmm come
that's his all this time anyhow so she
does that and then as she was arrested
because she served them in an Ohio
restaurant as chicken dumplings and then
this is her mug shot which is
fascinating her face if this is real is
yeah if this is real this is her face my
eye is up here yeah
it looks fake though right yeah that's
how the birds don't that's how she gets
the birds cuz you know how you gotta
like dive below him to catch him you
know how when you spear fish you have to
go below fish she's got to grab she got
to grab it an anchor so one of those
eyes he hazarded answering street birds
and serving them as chicken dumplings
it's kind of genius what did she do
wrong it's enterprise she's a master at
capture if she cooked the bird all the
way there was no disease left right cuz
everything cooks off at a certain what
is it what did she do
yeah she just met if she didn't say
chicken EE if she said watching us
waiting for dumplings I should have told
him where they came from
that's probably little bird dump listed
I hope this is real this should be real
right it was on the news Trump would say
no what might not be awkward I know
that's the most interesting thing it's
hard to look at and I don't want to make
fun of her because that's not to be mean
but it's really odd it's very odd
looking could you ever fix that
there's no way plastic surgery sure for
sure what do you mean they grew and they
grew in the ear on a guy's forehead you
can do anything
they'd have to move the eye down and
shift your day to break your eye bone
and move it down I know a guy that got
jumped in college and they they they
ruined his face cuz he had a head like
major reconstructive surgery he got
jumped in the streets dude it's
disgusting his face
unbelievable what they were able to do I
mean do they they cracked it inside of a
face they almost made him go blind
cracked his iPhone you know had deep
brain damage his entire jaw was
shattered no they beat the [ __ ] they
yeah I was disgusting
five guys jump to one guy cowards bad
guys bad guys men just tell you that
young men will kill you men get killed
just hit just go one on one
nope not those guys I knew guys like
that back in the day five guys on one
[ __ ] stop you die yeah you die huh
what's the next card event that soon got
me sad great this is a happy story Kevin
Smith
so he lost weight you know this is a
picture from a while ago so yeah
yeah cuz it had a heart attack for Kevin
that was a while ago this like 2015 he
lost 85 pounds nice I got him now [ __ ]
that's he actually looks like he's lean
yeah he does actually yeah I [ __ ]
there's a lot of loose skin that's a
whole nother thing they got to deal with
then you know I watch that 600 pound
life they got so much loose skin yeah I
know somebody who had that taken out you
do you cut it off it slice it yeah so
about together look at that he looks
good I don't know him at all you know
him great guy
you know I don't know where Derek comes
on the shows - funniest [ __ ] yeah I
don't know I mean I know who he is but I
don't know him as a person but he seems
like a nice smart and funny such a good
guy all the way around he's directed me
in an episode of the Kohlberg's - he
says what he did he directs Kohlberg's
yeah he's just great who's your favorite
director over there
well David Katzenberg is awesome he does
the bulk of him but I loved him too I
mean okay what you're saying you saying
you like you like Kevin Smith more than
Katzenberg know I like you think
Katzenberg's not as talented as Kevin
Smith that's such an odd thing to say
Bryan Callen said isn't as talented
no David choice David Katzenberg is
younger than that he'll never have you
on the show now but because I told I
told Ike as I said what you said you son
of a [ __ ] mm-hmm he's to be rowing me I
would love to be I would love to be on
that show just to uh I'll get you on
just to show them what good acting is
dude cause they was dealing with your
[ __ ] some auditions let me look at
me all right for the same offer only the
same go I love you red hair you might
you're my son you've decided you want to
go blonde you know it's gonna
infuriate me as your dad mm-hmm you're
afraid of me
mm-hmm tell me that you're gonna dye
your hair blonde that's the scene and
actually dad I wanted to talk to you
about something what's going on you're
not quitting baseball not quitting
baseball star that's you know I love the
hot pocket I'll always be a shortstop
all right good stuff what's going on I
don't know I I'm not afraid of telling
you the truth right I've always told you
the truth I hope so you know what
happens if you don't I know I see what
you do to mom and take
ya gotta take my belt off I know and
then those pants won't stay up with that
belt on keep it down ha oh yeah cooking
high now saying when that water boils
I'm not a I'm not I'm not ashamed of our
heritage you shouldn't be ashamed of our
heritage
we're scotch-irish that's right well the
fire haired people the berserks we kept
scotland safe from those goddamn limey
wolf
dad dad and mom dad walkers Sundance
coming in with their Prima not they're
taking our women on the first night oh
boy and that's why I know you're gonna
hold that sword higher my son our crest
right there yeah I see it I can't wait
till you turn 18 because we're gonna
burn that into your chest the way it was
burned into my chest what son well about
that fire heads if I'm gonna dye my hair
blonde there's a girl and she said she
she said she'd blow me if I dye my hair
pop I've never got my penis touched by
hand or mouth and I feel like I should I
know you're joking around right now and
pop I'm dyeing my hair I've made up my
mind he's just talking nonsense right
now are you top I love you but I'm gonna
dye my hair you don't know nothing you
got no respect for anything now and now
I'm gonna kick the dog to death oh I'm
gonna kick the dog's death pop you tell
me that you're joking I'm just joking
all right Oh pistol I was about to get
my kicked boots on I know father and
kick that [ __ ] dog and I would've
broken my heart as much as it breaks
your heart you know what what's that
never gonna dye my hair pop you know why
why I get plenty ahead there it is did I
get the wrong that was really good send
that tape out good stuff next next next
I got a pee-pee show we're gonna go you
all I just do one more than one yells do
one more all right so what do you think
about Serena Williams having her cat
suit and first of all oh they banned it
babe and did you see the Nike commercial
that just came out today no I tweeted it
please watch this real quick it's 60
seconds go go commercial okay oh yeah
you can go to sweater you go inter
Santino Twitter such a badass yeah two
things
one who banned it the Tennis Association
yeah yeah
go click on that [ __ ] video look at
that look at this video turn up the
volume this is beautiful
this made me cry you gotta start from
the beginning because you'll miss the
first line alright ready this is you at
the US Open this is you this serious
motion very good keep the perfect
service motion you have chills
ready I got chills Oh quick to the
backhand lean into it just Allah to take
the net
[Applause]
make sure you controlling a bone every
shot there you go very good back back
back
clear away heat up just like you want to
win just like you at the us to open
damn it this is you
hey by the way by the way dad's one of
the best come graduation gonna have
credit dad doesn't that is one of the
best commercials I've ever seen in my
life I got kids man and I think about
this all the time like how hard did you
push him he made champions out of those
kids champions world arguably I don't
know enough about tennis I'll be the
greatest female player of all time you
mean two black women who are an example
to everybody not just black women but
everybody I mean come on man I'm just
saying that man believer some [ __ ] yeah
anyway let's go to this [ __ ] article
about someone trying to ban her outfit
so it says French tennis federation
president bernard jewy de chelly
announced a dress code st. players must
respect the game and please let me tell
you something you're gonna ban this one
referring it first of all it covers
everything it's just skin tight yeah in
a sport that has sexualized women for
decades they were short short skirts
they short skirts they tuck balls into
the onion to the end of their skirts and
you're telling me that you can't cover
up your skin but it's too tight that's
obsessive surd [ __ ] that is how is that
more sexual than a short skirt let me
tell you something when I was a kid and
I would watch tennis matches of those
short skirts I thought that was the
sexiest [ __ ] I ever saw in my life yeah
how is that more sexual and it's always
had a really complicated relationship
with clothing well with fashion is
always lacked because of it yeah and in
Wilmington you always had to wear white
and there's always been that issue well
you know what that is that the woman was
just fine for taking her shirt off there
certain yeah so tennis has always had
very very specific but see you know
what's so funny
golf golf doesn't the golf has done this
one turns out it's sports bra it was
turned up like backwards so she had to
put on the front way if she got fine for
that she that's fine for that I wish I
was rich enough I'd pay that fine just
to [ __ ] show up yeah all she do is
switch it around because she's probably
uncomfortable yeah cause it was on the
wrong way yeah she probably didn't like
it yeah she wore a sports bra underneath
yep you see worse at the beach of course
you do they got some ridiculous insane
men can take their shirts off but they
do all the time yeah like me I love when
you take your shirt have a great body
you got a good body I have a great body
it's good no but I was just I'm saying
it's good enough modest party
comedy where you know the best body in
comedy I want it so you know I don't
care what year I just won I just 2018
it's the fourth year in a row I don't
care about it I'm just it's just what
the committee said you don't have the
best body in comedy I just said talk to
the tippy [ __ ] talk to the committee
the community committee on aesthetics in
comedy I don't care I don't give a [ __ ]
there it's a bunch of experts but I
don't I don't care I'm not I don't care
about this see is the CIC the cat the
committee of aesthetics and comedy yeah
nobody talk to the cat well you can make
you want to argue I'm not in fairness we
have a cat's phone number over there cuz
I'll bring their [ __ ] mom sabbatical
right now anyway
oh the CAC is on sabbatical yeah they're
in its Capri hold on I just got a text
from them oh yeah the techs from the CAC
yeah what are the comedy aesthetic
communications you're you're a shoo-in
for the 2019 Wow
well congrats bro yeah I'm a little bit
jealous I'm not even gonna lie
yeah she have any crickets that's good
that's good to hear well I'm glad you're
doing well listen Andrew this has been a
ruse has been so fun man I would love to
come back every time don't know coming
back every week every week a part of the
pocket well I am now
all right don't be lighter on the ginger
don't you're out I'm in John the fighter
in the gin Sean say that - that's yeah
your ions on sabbatical because he got
he's got stuff to do with the cab all
she knows available you're being super
district but let me tell you something
what I can't wait until they move you
out of here and me into here John
Brendan shop Andrew Santino the future
of the fighter and the gin not a fighter
in the gin no this is insulting your
your and the kid what kind of joke is
this here 108 years old Andrew Santino
is gonna be here the fighter and the
ginge is the future of this Ramadi
reading this is the bad taste in my
mouth I like it I like it I like it
no you're being irreverent the fighter
and the ginger chairs are red my
attitude is hot your crew loves me no
she loves me he loves me you're gone not
your people
see you later bribry goddammit yeah
Linden this is a fighter to kid we're
out that was [ __ ] great podcast
that's a [ __ ] great podcast so much
meet you actually